foreign
so welcome my name is efferenko and I'm
an associate professor here at MIT in
the department of brain cognitive
sciences and the McGovern Institute and
welcome to all of you from our research
team and the McGovern Institute more
generally we're very happy you're all
here and thank you for volunteering your
wonderful brains for research we hope to
share some preliminary findings with you
a little later so um my thank yous for
making this event possible will come a
little later
so I'll just say that um this is
hopefully this will be a nice
celebration of all of our
um love of language and Linguistics in
general and con Links of course in
particular and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to introduce all four speakers
for the first session and then we're
just gonna rotate through the talks
um and we'll try to stay on time as much
as possible
so it's my great pleasure to introduce
our four wonderful conlang creators I'll
go in turn so we have in turn of how
they're gonna speak so David and Jesse
will co-present so David Peterson got
his undergraduate degree at Berkeley and
his graduate degree from UC San Diego in
2007 he co-founded the language creation
society which many of you may be very
familiar with and he was its president
for a few years in 2015 he published the
book The Art of language invention which
again many of you may be familiar with
and perhaps most famously he created all
of the fictional languages for the Game
of Thrones along with several others for
other shows and such uh Jesse Sams is
now a professor of linguistics at
Stephen Austin State University she got
her undergraduate degree at Truman State
and then her PhD from University of
Colorado Boulder Boulder and she um more
generally so she teaches a class on
invented languages but her main job is
she works on syntax and semantics and uh
Linguistics of dialogue uh and in 2008
since 2019 she's been a professional con
Langer for the series motherland Fort
Salem
okay then we have Mark Oakland he's over
there um so Mark got his undergraduate
degree at Santa Cruz a lot of
Californians here uh he got his PhD at
Berkeley and he was then a professor
there for a few years no not there at
Santa Barbara still in California
um and then for many years he worked at
the national captioning Institute and he
actually I just learned this today that
he helped develop the first closed
captioning system for um uh those uh
with hearing impairments and at some
point in the early 80s while I guess
working for captioning one of the Oscars
he met the producer of the movie Star
Trek 2 and eventually got hired by
Paramount to create Klingon and
subsequently he published three books
about Klingon and developed several
other conlings
okay and last but not least we have fall
from right here uh and Paul got his
bachelor's uh in math from University of
Rochester uh then he taught English and
math in Malaysia with a preschool for a
few years uh and eventually got kind of
increasingly interested in linguistics
and ended up getting a PhD at the
University of Southern California I
guess it was like an 81 then he worked
in industry for a few years and then he
returned to the USC business school
where he is now a professor of
management communication and of course
most famously for all of us in 2009 Paul
was chosen as a creator of the navi
language
for Avatar okay so let's give a warm
welcome to um David and Jesse
there we go all right so we've been
working together since 2019 and as a
brief recap overview of what we've done
together uh our first job that we worked
together was the mainiche language for
motherland Fort Salem since then we have
founded Lang time studio where we create
languages for anthropomorphic animals
and so far we have four languages going
we've got languages for rabbits possums
mice and cats next season when we start
that it'll be for dogs
and we've also worked on a shadow and
Bone together specifically second season
and moving forward and we worked on the
show paper girls uh where we created a
language called queua and we were very
excited about it only to find out that
they cut all of it from the actual show
um but but we did it
[Music]
um and we're also now working on
spin-offs for The Witcher so while I'm
not working on the henling I'm with uh
David we are working on spin-off
projects together
uh we also worked on uh the ajinometry
language which appeared in a Vampire
Academy on the peacock and you know I'm
gonna plug that now watch it get it a
second season because it's a lot of fun
for us to work on
um if you don't like vampires just close
your eyes while the TV is on for an hour
it's fine
and uh also I started working with David
on Dune on the second Dune movie which
will at some point be out
so by the numbers in the past three
years we have created 12 language
sketches 10 full con links two partial
projects I consider them partial when I
joined David halfway through the
language creation process and we've got
another six plus projects in the
pipeline so we're we're 30 projects
strong so we feel like we can
confidently talk about uh collaborative
conlanging here
no so uh conlanging tends to be a solo
activity this is I think what most
conlangers know but even so there are
many times where conlingers have worked
together to collaborate in fact my first
one would have been uh I would say in
early 2001
um with the old old project where we all
tried to create different daughter
languages from one proto-language
um anyway but uh the question is like
how do you do it most effectively
because I I've done it many many times
over the past 22 years very few times
has actually been very effective uh and
so we wanted to talk about were kind of
five habits of of happy conling uh
collaborators and and emphasize happy
here because you actually can do work
that is effective without necessarily
enjoying the pro the process
um and I've done it all three ways
really I've done you know very good
conlang work uh that I was very happy
with with Jesse very good conlane worked
where I just did not enjoy the process
at all and just very poor conlang work
and actually both of those too there
were a couple that were really fun we
just didn't do very much or do it very
well
um but uh the the number one uh Factor
here is respect and this is uh I think
most important for for happiness the
respect has to go both ways and it has
to be for every single person uh
involved in the in the process in other
words you have to respect each other's
different work Styles because as all
conlingers know
um we kind of tend to work differently
there are very few conlingers that work
exactly the same some like to be very
very methodical some like to start in
one place versus another and so you have
to respect that the person that you're
working with may work differently from
you but is still going to work
effectively and then you also have to
Value their intellectual input and so
another I mean yeah I know laughing
we're not going to talk about the the
bad ones but I mean you have to you have
to respect the person that you're
working with you know is a conlinger in
their own right it is a good con Langer
and has some really valuable
um input to give to the process so that
ultimately the result is you know your
Collective vision and not just one
person's Vision where every so often
somebody else gets to chime in
division it really helps if you actually
Share A Creative Vision as you're
working on on a project together uh and
so every project brings its own unique
challenges and so figuring out how to
have a different Creative Vision for
every project can be a daunting task
um but it is one that conlingers
Undertake and if you don't have a vision
that you share with your partner it will
go wonky pretty quickly and I think this
is one of the biggest problems because
we have also seen
um with our link time studio Community a
lot of people trying to get together to
create collaborative conlangs and they
usually fall apart somewhere around week
three
of work and that's partially because
everybody on the project came into it
with a completely different idea for
what they wanted to do with the language
and they couldn't figure out how to make
those Visions come together as a unified
unit so you really have to be able to
share the larger goal goals of the
language with your partner or partners
and so then you also have to have a team
approach to solving all of the many
challenges that are going to be thrown
your way from not just you know what
sounds are we going to have and how are
they going to shift but then also how
are we going to grow this vocabulary and
start actually doing translations and so
all the challenges across the projects
you really have to come together and
have a teamwork attitude it doesn't work
to just say well this is what I'm doing
I don't care what you want on the
vocabulary that never works except when
I tell you this word has to be in it
then it works
so uh splitting tests this is actually
one of the places where I think
conlanging is
um working as a team on a Conley can
actually be quite effective because
creating a language feels like one big
task but it's actually not it's a whole
bunch of very very very different tasks
so um I don't know what this uh yeah
anyway that was just what I said I'm
just going to look at the two things
that it says and then I'm gonna say
stuff so
um anyway but like if you think about it
especially just out of curiosity because
I know that there are many people here
who came because you've studied uh one
or more languages how many people are
actually language creators raise your
hands
you raise them high yeah there we go
nice all right so those of you who have
created languages will know this others
uh who haven't uh will learn this but
it's a very different thing to create a
phonological system the sound system and
language versus creating for example the
verbal system of a language versus
creating vocabulary versus creating
idioms versus creating a unique writing
system if you have that even slightly
separate from designing a romanization
system which is just how you write it
with the Roman alphabet all of these are
slightly different tasks that engage
slightly different areas of your brain
they're obviously all involved in the
overall project but they kind of speak
to different sides of your personality
and if there are conlingers out there
who for example I I've heard this a lot
who are really interested in grammar and
come up with really interesting grammar
systems but shut down when it comes to
creating vocabulary
uh I mean there's a reason for that
these are two very very different tasks
and because of that it makes sense that
you could actually split these tasks
amongst team members right you just go
essentially go to your strengths for
somebody I mean anybody who's done this
there are people who love creating like
noun class systems or case systems there
are people who love verbs there are
those who love vocabulary generation for
those of you who don't believe it it's
true I'm one of those people I love
vocabulary generation and there are
conlingers who would be very happy if
like say they were set a conlang task if
all they were doing was creating noun
cases and so this is the type of thing
where it's like you have to figure out
where the strengths of your team members
where do they lie where they're their
interests lie and maybe just decide all
right you know what I'm going to back
off from this part of it and just focus
on this part and then of course the
division is important and also the trust
is important because if you give
somebody the task of saying all right
you're in charge of the noun cases
system then they are in charge of the
noun case system and you at the
phonology don't get to come in and say
well you know what maybe you should
probably do this and this and this it's
like no no that's not how Division and
Trust works so it's really I think
creating a language it really helps like
it's something that you can do as a team
everybody just needs to be on board
everybody needs to be on the same page
and this is especially important when
you get hired for a job and get told you
need to have this language done in 10
days
of course
yeah that was fun
um you also it really helps if you have
matching work ethics and uh by this I
mean like you both bring or all if it's
more than two people bring meaningful
contributions to the project but also
time efficient ones because creative
types especially have all sorts of
different styles of how they get to
their you know level of creativity and
if you're on a project with a deadline
whether it's a class project or you know
a professional one you have to make sure
that the work gets done and so if you
are a creative type that just needs a
lot of downtime where you do no work at
all and then the last 24 hours you don't
sleep and you just get it all done at
once because your brain has been
percolating the entire time that's not
going to work so well with somebody who
needs to have a different you know style
a different approach to how they they
work on the project and so it really
again it just breaks down to being able
to divide and and Conquer so to speak
and knowing that you're both going to be
doing it in a Time effective way and
that you can this is I think built into
uh respect as well I think it can be
really hard to respect other people's
work processes that are so different
from your own uh that like you can't
understand what they're doing
um and so you can't respect like if they
need that downtime to percolate ideas
you look at them and say well gosh
you're not doing anything thanks uh and
so that like you know builds a bit of
resentment but if you understand it
because that's how you work too then you
can support each other in the process
and so if the way that you work actually
matches it really really helps
uh I will say that for the previous uh
collaborations I've done this is
honestly where things break down the
most
um it's not you know respect usually
you're getting together with people you
like it's and everybody knows their
strengths and they're really engaged in
it but it's the type of thing where one
person sits down and does like you know
seven pages of grammar in 24 hours and
the other person isn't doing anything
and sometimes gets a little bit turned
off by that because they look and say oh
well they did all that much and I didn't
really do anything and then they're just
less engaged and basically once
somebody's not engaged then pretty soon
they're out of it and pretty soon it
just dies so yeah this one's really
important last one is uh having to leave
voice and I think this is important
especially especially for a job uh where
it's just like there's just somebody at
the top that is kind of guiding things
basically when it's like it could be
this or that somebody is there to make a
decision
um and so it's important to have a lead
for each task I think and then of course
course they have to be a good leader and
be sure to respect you know what
everybody else is doing and compromise
like and a great example of this was on
the second season of Shadow and Bone we
had two full languages to do and
basically we just um we didn't split
them up in that we did separate
languages but basically I was the lead
on zemany and uh Jesse was the lead on
Shu and so we kind of worked on you know
kind of parts of it separately the way
we did and then we came together but it
was like when it comes to who is the
best person with this language who's the
one that's calling the shots it was
Jesse for shoe and then me for zemini
and it just works a little bit better as
long as like everybody is on board with
it because of course if somebody thinks
they're the lead but nobody else does
that of course leads to problems so it's
like kind of a lot of the stuff that you
learned working on group projects in
high school for things that you didn't
want to do are still important when it
comes to doing stuff you actually want
to do so
um go for it oh yeah this is just the
summary so but yeah like a lot of this
is just repeating what you would learn
in teamwork but um I think it's really
interesting uh when it gets applied to
especially very creative projects like
conlanging uh because there are of
course systematic decisions that we make
but at the same time there are also
um very creative processes that have to
go in and that can be difficult
under Underneath It All that respect is
so important because you just have to be
able to say yes these are good ideas
that that you have
um and you have to respect that and so
this is thank you in many of our
languages
thank you for being here thank you for
listening and we're very excited thank
you to MIT and all the people who work
to make this happen because this is
pretty amazing so thank you and if you
want to find us on social media you can
find us on Instagram together at link
time studio
um or separately I'm at quothal linguist
and David is at davrasar all right
cool
okay so I think we have five minutes for
questions
oh are we I thought we were doing one
next to
oh we're good yeah
I'm ready to run
scripts yeah
do they let you do that or is that like
the set designer or the
um if they're if they're up there we did
it
um but uh but no that's that's a very
mixed bag
um sometimes we get to do it sometimes
we get to do one uh and then sometimes
we don't it's usually better when we do
it yeah
yeah
um so I know you get done a lot of work
for a lot of shows and movies and all
that any if you can say any projects in
the work for any Star
okay no
it was a I was interviewed for a Star
Wars show once and then they never got
back to me
we win that yeah
sorry
uh yes on the back
yes yes
so we actually that's usually where we
start is working with their production
team on the show or movie and they tell
us what they're looking for in the
language and it usually is some sort of
aesthetic description that quite often
makes no sense to us really uh because
it's like we want it to be melodic but
Gutta role in very linguistical in style
and we're like all right
um and so usually it's it's we're kind
of working through all that to figure
out how to create something that will
sound a way to them that that they're
happy with but yeah we always start with
here here's a sound system what do you
think
oh we got here and then here
um are you usually working with phrases
sometimes they're dealing with phrases
that they give you like oh we want these
characters to say these things and then
to translate
or are you
we need a language and then you provide
them the language and Foundation
uh it's mostly the latter
um honestly the only times where there
have been phrases was when it came from
books like when it was when it was just
a show it was uh it's never been the
case that they've had you know set
phrases they wanted them to say ahead of
time there have been character names
sometimes that needed to be incorporated
or sometimes even the name of the
language itself but uh but no not set
phrases that was only from books and
then it's like a little bit up to
interpretation how you read it yeah
um have you noticed have you noticed any
differences between languages that you
created solo and languages that you
created collaboratively with somebody
else yeah the languages that create with
Jesse are better
I mean uh there's I I think that I think
that each of us has a definite style
when you look at languages that we've
just done on our own you can tell
um but um I I think I think we balance
each other out a lot better
um I think it comes off better overall I
agree
very subjective yeah
talked about how you split up the tasks
so like one person can do the vocabulary
technology
and all that are there major like
structural decisions you have to make
together first before you split up and
do your own
path there well there could be uh
decisions at the top level that could be
done together but also for some projects
we just don't have the time and so we
just have to again when we assign sort
of a lead voice like you're going to be
the lead on this uh that person really
decides the structure and then we both
work within those parameters I would
also say that like vocabulary is usually
the last part so it's it's like if you
were to assign one person vocabulary
like they wouldn't be doing anything for
a bit because like you know the language
has to get built up a bit first before
you get there I think we have time for
one more yeah sort of related to that
question
um I guess I guess it's solved by
vocabular time coming class but if
there's like idioms for example are
dependent on vocabulary existing how do
you deal with
Israel depending on someone else like I
said just a scheduling thing whereas
first well I was going to say when we
create idioms usually like if one of us
has an idea it's a semantic based one
and then we'll look and be like do we
have a word in the language yet if we
don't now we need to work together to
create a word to to be able to use for
it and so it's sort of it we come to
each other with ideas at that point yeah
yeah and I think it actually works out
really well just like you just have an
idea like I think it would be really
cool if we had this idiom that was this
and then we we was like I'm like yeah
that's a great idea now let's see what
vocabulary we need to create to support
that usually works out all right so I
think for trying to come up with common
greetings and uh jacobsa for Dune it was
I just had essentially I was
brainstorming pages of ideas for like we
could use this expression this
expression ran them all by David and he
picked his favorite yeah it was good all
right it's moving along
foreign
I should introduce myself I'm Marco cran
my connection all this stuff is going on
mostly although I've done some other
things too
uh what I'm going to talk about is very
different from what David and Jesse
talked about obviously because I did it
all by myself uh or started anyway doing
it all by myself
um
so what I thought I would talk about is
sort of where Klingon came from and how
it got to be the the way it turned out
to be or is or how it's becoming or
something like that
um when you make up a language or more
accurately in in my case and in their
case too when you make up a language for
somebody else
uh you don't start from nothing it comes
with instructions or at the very least
there's some kind of a world where it's
where it's going to fit in that where
it's going to be apart
and for Klingon of course that world is
Star Trek
and if we look back at the original
series from from the 1960s you know
where it all began
we don't learn a whole lot about various
alien languages
and that's because for the most part the
idea of different species from the
Galaxy speaking different languages was
just ignored
that is everybody everywhere spoke
English
or whatever language the show happened
to be dubbed into the show did
acknowledge the idea of different
species speaking different languages
uh
they uh
talk about a device that they would need
so that they could understand everybody
and eventually they call that a
universal translator but for the most
part no English is just the lingua Franc
of the Galaxy
um for Klingons in particular we know
they had their own language we know that
from from the get-go one of the original
episodes trouble with triples there's a
Klingon guy named corax who insists that
half the quadrant is learning to speak
what he calls Klingon ease
but we never hear cling on ease because
he doesn't speak it he only speaks
English as do all of the other Klingons
in Star Trek in the original series
the so apparently the universal
translator is either in operation on all
the time I don't know what was going on
there which is not to say there was no
alien dialogue in Star Trek um we heard
some Vulcan for example the original
series there's words like Lipa which is
some kind of a weapon
um
this Vulcan certainly was not a conlang
with the possible exception of a
one-word sentence kroika which means
stop it's command that means stop it
consisted only of a bunch of nouns and
the phonology was generally just English
phonology with syllables kind of jumbled
up in in some funny way uh but they
started getting a little bit uh language
Savvy with the first movie Star Trek the
motion picture at the beginning of that
film Spock you know Spock is
participating in a ritual called kolinar
and when they filmed the scene the
dialogue was in English
but in post-production they change it to
Vulcan uh and the reason for changing it
makes sense uh from a story point of
view because we're watching an ancient
Vulcan ceremony on the Vulcan planet and
there's nobody around except Vulcans so
of course they should be talking Vulcan
but the real reason they made the change
that the Hollywood Insider reason they
made the change is they just didn't like
the way it sounded
um but this Vulcan was not a conlang
either because what they did since it
was already filmed is create
gobbledygook
that when spoken matched the lip
movements of the English that was
already there and then the actor dubbed
it in
okay so it's like dubbing in a foreign
language in a film except for the lips
that the mouth had to had to match of
course when they were off camera they
could do whatever they wanted but it was
mostly this lip syncing thing
real conlanging in Star Trek began with
Star Trek 3 Search for Spock but the
roots uh or the first glimmers or
whatever of the language were probably
but not for probably we're we're
definitely in the first movie Star Trek
the motion picture which was five years
before that in the very very beginning
of that film there's Klingons uh and one
of them speaks this strange language no
one has ever heard before and their
subtitles that that's a real thing there
was not very many lines there's I don't
know eight or nine or ten of these lines
they're just he's just barking out
commands for the most part which means
evasive
Fire and Fire the torpedo
uh that dialogue that language if you
will was prevented by invented by a
couple of people John povill who was one
of the producers and James Dewan the guy
who played Scotty all the time those two
guys povill uh described the language
this is his words as nonsense syllables
it's clicks and Grunts and hisses which
is not a very good description of a con
line I would hope
but it was a start and for Star Trek 3
the the writer and producer of that harv
Bennett he's the one who decided there
should be a Klingon language and he
hired me the idea was to start with the
words and sounds and syllables that were
heard in the motion picture but we
wanted to get beyond the
Grunts and hisses so we decided to come
up with a complete language in other
words do conlanging
and I just said the idea was to come up
with a complete language that's not
really true because all I set out to do
at first was to come up with what was
needed for the film and nothing more so
I approached my task in the same way I
said designer or set builder approaches
their task in other words if you have a
a movie set you know the looks really
good from the front but the back is just
plywood held up by two by fours if
there's a door but in the scene that you
never have to open the door the door
doesn't open right on the set and the
language was the same way if they had to
say it in the film I made up what you
needed to do to say it and if it didn't
come up in the film I didn't make it up
so the language was it was extremely
extremely sketchy uh at the very very
beginning
um and when you construct the language
step one I think or maybe Step Zero uh
is to know who the speakers are you know
uh and how who's going to make use of
this language
so who or what are Klingons for one
thing we know they're not human
therefore they should not speak a human
language they speak a non-human language
well what does that mean
uh well language is human languages
anyway uh have certain things in common
to be overly simplistic you know things
like consonants and vowels and words and
stuff uh they have certain Tendencies
certain sounds tend to go together in
the same language certain grammatical
features tend to go together the same
language as certain ones don't some
features are a lot more common in the
world than others and stuff
uh so to make Klingon a non-human
language it made sense to violate or
steer away from some of these rules and
tendencies and and commonalities these
these things are sometimes called
universals though in the context of Star
Trek applying the word universals to
just Earth languages seems kind of
pretentious anyway
since Klingon isn't a human language it
doesn't have to pay strict attention to
these human language rules on the other
hand there was a practical matter to
consider because all of the actors who
are going to speak this language were
human
and they had to be able to say the lines
um so there wasn't going to be any
electronic enhancement or play tapes
backwards you know or any of that kind
of stuff so out of uh deference to the
humanness of the actors
all of the Sounds in Klingon can be
found in some human language or other
but the collection is unique no human
language is likely to have that
particular set of sounds and so the
language sounds a bit bizarre for that
reason and this bizarreness actually
makes Klingon difficult to pronounce
if you do it correctly
um but that's okay because for the
actors after practicing a few times
they'd only have to pronounce the lines
if we're lucky once or twice right then
they take the the take is over and they
never have to say the line ever again in
their whole life right so it was okay if
it was hard
um
I also tried to you know the same
approach in uh with the grammar to make
the grammar unusual you know for a
simple sentence that has a subject and a
verb and an object those three elements
have to come in some order or other
and uh if you mathematically there's six
possibilities subject verbiological so
on there's there's six ways you can flip
them around if you look around the world
I don't know 87 or so of the languages
have on Earth
um have the subject that comes the
subject comes first
about one percent
are languages where the object comes
first
therefore for Klingon the object comes
first because in a funny way it's the
least human
so I made up playing on versions of all
the lines that the script said somebody
is speaking Klingon
I also made him Klingon virgins of all
the lines where Klingons were speaking
English to each other
in in case well the you know the filming
process was going on someone would say
hey why are the Klingons talking English
to each other they should talk clean I
could say here say this they use zero of
those lines
but it helped flesh out the language
that was it was it was a good thing to
do but that's it I didn't make up
anything else absolutely nothing else
and I at the time I had no reason to
believe that there would ever be a need
to make up anything else
then filming began and now this made up
language such as it was comes face to
face with reality that means filmmaking
so on the set my job was to coach the
actors and approve the takes right out
each time after after the the scene was
filmed the director would say how was
the Klingon and if it was okay I'd say
okay and if it was not okay I would say
it was not okay I learned very quickly
not to give that second answer very
often
but I kept track of what was going on if
it was a kind of a trivial mistake if
the actor said toe but he was supposed
to say two
say okay fine from now on the word is
toe so it changed sometimes depending on
which syllable uh the actor
mispronounced or dropped out or
something there might be an effect on
the grammar so not only did the sounds
the particular words change but the
grammar changed
um
but you know overall the actors did a
good job I was I was pleased I was able
to work in all these changes into the
into the language so it was okay
and I went home figuring that I was
finished
but then they went into post-production
and this had an effect on the language
as well for one thing they changed their
mind and now the klingon's talking
English to each other sometimes we're
supposed to talk Klingon but I couldn't
give them all those phrases they made it
before because it's already filmed so we
had to go back to the lip syncing
technique and then make up Klingon to
match the lips but now I'm constrained
by the sound system of Klingon and the
grammar and vocabulary and all this kind
of stuff
or they left the soundtrack alone but
they changed the subtitles so there's a
line come up which originally meant I
told you engine only this is just to
destroy the engine
but the subtitle says I wanted prisoners
okay what are we gonna do well the
object comes first so come up who is the
first words that must mean prisoners and
so on so anyway it was able to make it
work now during this time I wrote a book
called The Klingon dictionary which
contains all of the words from the
movies and and and and some more stuff
and a description of the grammar and I
said great now my con line is in print
I can look up the words I can look up
the grammatical rules I don't have to
remember any of this stuff and this made
everything harder
um
because working on the next films that
had Klingon in them this was Star Trek
five and six I had to go by the book and
if the actor made a mistake
right I still had to follow the book so
now the actor said toe instead of two I
had to make up a whole word toe but that
didn't you know did make the original
two disappear and so on it was it was a
tricky tricky thing trickier thing to do
um at about this time the Star Trek was
getting into into high gear Star Trek
the Next Generation was going followed
by Deep Space Nine and voyage and all
the all these other things
and there was lots more Klingon uh in
these TV shows and and later movies the
writers of those shows seem to have
liked the language because they because
they used it a lot but how accurate the
language was dependent on who the writer
or producer was and something that's who
the actor was and they had different
approaches
uh sometimes they would consult with me
sometimes they would just find the
dictionary and go through it and
sometimes they found the right words
sometimes they get the pronunciation
right mostly not
sometimes they found what they thought
were the right words
but they ignored the grammar entirely
and sometimes in fact most of the time
they just made stuff up
but if a character said it in Star Trek
and a TV show in a movie that made it
automatically legit so I had to
incorporate it into the language somehow
to order if it was kind of cling on eyes
the whole thing
when I wrote the book The Klingon
dictionary which is almost 40 years ago
which is absolutely
scary
um I hoped of course you know that
people would buy it but what I didn't
realize is uh how closely they would
read it and
study it and analyze it and a whole new
subculture developed of Klingon speakers
uh the internet was getting going at
about the same time and I think that
played a role because the good people
could find each other
and this klingon-speaking community
including especially some members of
this Klingon speaking Community who are
there somewhere
um are unbelievably creative and they
translate and write songs and stories
and books or they just carry on
discussions
and as they do this they've discovered
let's say some gaps
in the language and they ask for more
especially vocabulary that they need
because they want to talk about the
things that those of us on Earth
talk about
um
and and I provide that probably at a
much more sluggish rate than people
would like but it happens the
significant thing though
is that there's been a shift in Klingon
of what influences or or instigates or
Spurs on the growth of the language has
shifted from Hollywood producers and
writers to speakers of the language uh
are sort of responsible for for the
shape that it's taking
um another interesting thing that's come
about as a result of this Klingon
speaking Community is that the producers
of Star Trek and some other shows and
and creators of other kinds of projects
have over the past I don't know five six
seven ten years or so
hired some really really good Klingon
speakers to do their Klingon translation
in fact
the currently running Star Trek shows
the ones who are on on I was going to
say on TV they're on streaming something
or other right now there's five of them
rotating around in some weird way
uh not all but most of the Klingon in
those shows
was provided by members of the Klingon
speaking Community not by me
um so just as there are speakers of
Spanish or French or Swahili or anything
else who can translate you know from
their languages there's Klingon speakers
who can provide the same sort of service
now I should note
that I don't feel pushed aside by that I
think I think it's great I think it's
terrific sort of what started out as a
as a very incomplete conlang uh there's
more more of a sketch has been pushed
and shoved and stretched in various
directions by multiple stakeholders into
a going
and and growing concern
uh I'm not sure where it's going next or
how it's how it's going to grow or how
it Compares with other languages
constructed and otherwise uh so I'll
stop now because I'm told my time is up
and also because I don't know what's
going to happen next so maybe maybe
these MRI things will tell us something
[Applause]
so
yeah
in a way sounds like the language ended
up developing like real languages do and
that it started off one way and then
like
so many different terms
um but I'm not despite my badge color so
it's speed Klingon I'm kind of curious
if you think that
it took too many turns and now it kind
of doesn't make a lot of linguistical
sense or does it like really kind of
look like English or something like that
well it yeah yeah no it doesn't look
like English
um
no you know it did take it did take
twists and turns but still in its own
world so to speak you know in it and
it's it follows the the the people who
speak it don't go off in 700 different
directions they pay very close attention
to what it is uh as I said that they're
created they as as need be well let me
take a step back they don't create any
new grammar they don't create any new
official vocabulary they do create slang
they're very clever about about coming
up with jargon for to discuss various
topics and stuff like that uh but uh
someone asked me the other day is is
there an Academy of Klingon or something
like that you know making all these
decisions and judgments and I'm standing
here
uh that was not my decision by the way
it was kind of thrust upon me
but for the time being that's that's the
way it works so yeah there are all all
kinds of constraints
are there any native speakers of Klingon
the short answer is no uh
slightly slightly longer answer is
there's one and maybe more attempts but
I know of one attempt to to raise a kid
uh to be to speak you know Klingon as as
he was growing up and that worked out
fine for a couple of years until the kid
discovered that nobody else there was
anybody else to talk to
and he lost interest altogether I know
this I know this kid he's about 25 years
old now and he's just fine
that has technology that we don't have
necessarily yeah well well the the
for
eign trying to think of the best way to
say I don't have to worry about that
because all the work I've done for the
TV show and for the movies
the writers decided what what it is that
the technology is and what they're going
to talk about and stuff like that where
the growth of the language has come from
it's not as I was saying it's not so
much that but it's from the people who
speak the language who don't want to
talk about iron transducer or something
or others but I want to talk about a
loaf of bread okay
yeah
do you think that the community and I
have the impression of doing reviews
like
um semantic and pragmatic influence
there's a lot of English influence in it
because most of the speakers are English
you're right about that but it's still
not English yeah
[Music]
[Music]
processing
we'll find out
um
that's that's what we're here for one of
the things that that maybe will this
this thing will show is is Klingon
different from other conlangs
okay because a lot of the other kinds
were designed more completely from the
get-go
okay whereas English uh Klingon grew as
as need be as need be as need be it's a
you know it's a different kind of thing
and it was designed not to be you uh you
know to use the words I was using before
not to be human-like whereas a lot of
these other languages were specifically
designed to be human-like so when we do
all this when you do all this brain
stuff we'll Klingon stand out in some
way different from some of the other
kinds I don't know we'll see
yeah in the back
yeah
yeah well most mostly what helps it have
exceptions and regularities when this is
when the writers make stuff up
one more one more
last one
um or like the grammar of vocabulary
that you introduced in the language when
when this like when the external forces
changed from the the movie uh
my my goals didn't change I I
stopped worrying so much about does it
fit into outer space
but everything else is the same
all right thank you very much
hello everybody it's a great pleasure to
be here
and a big thank you to EV and Saima and
Elise and everyone else instrumental in
putting this together I mean it's really
quite extraordinary what I thought I
would do is um talk a little bit about
the Genesis of Navi uh tell you some of
the highlights of its structure and then
uh say a few things about what has
happened to the language since uh Avatar
debuted in 2009.
so
when I got the assignment which was way
back in 2005
there were certain constraints I was
under
whoops some of them were will yeah
you know what's coming okay
so some of them were externally imposed
and some self-imposed the externally
imposed constraints came from this
gentleman here
James Cameron and so
um when Jim spoke to me what he wanted
was
an entirely new language not based on
anything else
he wanted it to sound nice of course
that is very much a subjective decision
there'll be uh no electronic
manipulation of the voices you've heard
this stuff before right right from Mark
same thing so that what the actors could
produce was what you would hear in the
movie theater uh
hello
here we go uh
he wanted me to stay consistent with his
original words he had come up with about
30 words of his own mainly uh names of
characters animals and so on the
language had to be learnable by humans
because that's part of the storyline and
of course it had to be feasible for the
actors
I also had a constraints that I imposed
upon myself one was that it had to stand
up to linguistic scrutiny I had a strong
suspicion that there'd be a contingent
among the moviegoers who would examine
the language pounce on it with a
microscope
uh which is what happened uh I wanted to
make it interesting to people who might
want to learn it I wanted to make it
unusual given that it's a uh it's an
alien language and then I wanted to
balance
complexity with accessibility which is
to say I wanted to avoid two extremes
one extreme would be create a language
with a grammar so incredibly complex
that people would just throw up their
hands in frustration The Other Extreme
would be to create something very very
accessible and very simplistic that
would just bore people to death
so
that being said
the linguistic structure and framework
which again is something that's very
very common to uh to Kai Langs
we talk about phonetics and phonology
the sounds and sound system of the
language morphology the word building
rules syntax and rules for putting words
together in phrases and sentences and
then the interplay between language
culture and environment
okay so let's uh let's begin delving
into phoneticine phenology here are the
consonants of Navi there are 20 of them
as you can see a lot of them are very
familiar this by the way is the not the
spelling system not IPA uh the most
interesting ones that have attracted the
most attention are the ones in the first
line the objectives these are popping
sounds that sound like and
they're actually found in real Earth
languages the apostrophe is not for
decoration it's a glottal stop it's a
real consonant it's what you hear in
English oh
Navi has seven vowels it has two pseudo
vowels which are consonants that kind of
behave like vowels and so we have words
like which means ground and which means
day four diphthongs uh
three of them are very familiar ow I a
and the fourth that sort of completes
the symmetrical set EO is also possible
it's a less familiar okay but if you
just got the sounds you still have a
long
uh process to develop the sound system
so for example
um where can the sounds exist in a
syllable Lingus will say what are the
phonotactic constraints well for example
only 12 consonants can be
in syllable final position and those are
the ones in red here so Navi has an S
but no not the word could possibly end
in s
uh what about consonant clusters
consonants that come together that abut
within a syllable we have no final
consonant clusters we do have initial
content in clusters and this is a
complete set
every initial concept I'm sorry every
initial consonant cluster has to begin
with one of the red sounds followed by
one of the blue signs but this excludes
a lot of very common uh consonant
clusters in English for example there's
no PL there's no KR
and so on uh what you do get is some
rather unusual looking consonant
clusters we have words like flop
vacuums Combs Elite
these are really fun to pronounce
uh okay but then there are pronunciation
rules
for example here are some six here are
six very common words in the language uh
Nadi is I to say in the I me is the word
for in so keep getting his world what's
in the world
you would think Mickey
okay and all of these initial consonants
change to other consonants through a
very systematic processes called
linishin uh so that's one of the
pronunciation rules of Navi if you speak
the language this has to become
absolutely automatic and second nature
to you
okay moving on to morphology what do the
verbs look like okay here's an example
uh
the verb for Hunt is Taron and here are
some inflected forms
and so on these mean things like has
hunted will hunt
uh may hunt in the future
has just hunted and I feel good about it
um
so what's happening so this is what's
happening uh the black elements are
meaningful elements morphemes that carry
information about tense and aspect and
attitude but rather than being prefixed
to a root or suffix to root their
infants they kind of shove right in the
middle of the root which is possible in
human languages but uh relatively rare
what about nouns and pronouns well uh
the protons are kind of interesting in
that they're gendered and non-gendered
forms so in Navi you never have to ask
someone what their pronouns are uh we
have words for sheep and he
pronouns but the more common term is
simply po which means either he or she
okay what about nouns well uh here is a
noun atokan is a character name and here
are the six different forms that the
noun
that the name can appear in uh and these
are six cases
uh navigate to what has what's called a
tripartite
case system so genitive data are very
familiar the first three need a little
bit of explanation so in a sentence like
John is sleeping that's an intransitive
structure
John is not doing anything to anything
else but in Mary ate the ice cream Mary
is doing something to ice cream so we
call John as for subject Mary is an
agent because she's doing something to
something else uh p is the patient
often called object uh what's unusual
about Navi is that all three of these
are marked differently now there are
Earth languages that do that they're
extraordinarily rare
so one thing the case system allows you
to do is uh have a lot of word order
flexibility so here are uh six different
ways to say a two kindnesses as Mark
said there are three factorial
permutations of of of three elements and
because of the case system every one of
these is grammatical and means the same
thing
uh now this word order flexibility is
something that permeates the language in
general modifiers can come either before
or after their heads so
um adjectives can come before or after
the noun you can say the equivalent of
new word or word new and you notice that
this a is a linking morpheme which
always comes between the noun and
adjective whether it precedes or or
follows uh
your father
can be either your father or father your
relative courses there's a sound that I
hear can also be the I hear it sound
uh we have ADD positions rather than
prepositions and and uh
so so Teddy Navi or naviteri is about
Navi
okay vocabulary how do you construct
words uh there are four different ways
essentially uh the least common is
borrowing there are certain situations
in which it is appropriate to borrow a
word the not the don't have a written
language they don't have books so in
order to say book they simply borrow the
English word
book
that's what it that's what the word book
comes out as when you filter it through
the navi sound system uh same thing for
gunship same thing for Earth
then there are derivational processes
which are very common a language you can
take for example a verb and change it
into a noun that on his hunt
the abstract concept of hunting sat out
on a hunt dot on you 100. you can also
combine existing items in interesting
ways so interesting is
NC which means actually exciting the
brain computer is L2 left
metal brain actually
and the components are knit which is an
adverbial element Tiff Cato which means
situation and guy which means true so
the word actually means new
situationally and then we have uh new
Roots Lord is beautiful every English
this is where you just make up words and
that's really kind of the fun part
that's where the art comes in I think uh
vertep is demon I sometimes had fun in
uh doing a little bit of iconicity where
the form of the word has something to do
with the meaning so due is easy it kind
of seemed like a nice easy kind of word
uh difficult
smooth as foul we and rough is okay
one of the most interesting things is to
adapt the language to its culture
environment sometimes even to the
physiology of the navi they have for
example four digits on each hand rather
than five so it seemed to me that they
would have a base eight counting system
and Jim Cameron said yep so uh the way
you count in Navi is one through eight
uh
and then nine is
essentially eight and one ten is eight
and two and so on uh there's an
honorific and ceremonial register of the
language used for special purposes where
things change the word for oh
the word for I rather is Owen but in the
ceremonial registry of his oh becomes a
yang
Lu to B becomes Lu you
and one of the most fun Parts which is
what I really love is to come up with
Proverbs idioms
um similes metaphors that would be
appropriate to the environment and to
the people so for example
um I'm sorry it's a semicune called
good action um
I'm sorry the tail and ears also speak
uh if you watch the movie The tails and
ears are very expressive and this is
saying uh don't just
listen to the words look at the body
language uh
this is a proverb that includes a little
bit of word play good action bad result
when you do something with best
intentions it doesn't come out well and
you have the word play between cam
action and Kum result
uh I like this
is a mantis a verb to whistle uh what it
means is don't expect someone to do
something that's not in their nature and
you have the word play between
which I kind of like uh finally
at the rip
um dripping water pierces Iraq is pretty
clear what that means leap is drip and
Reap is Pierce
okay so what's happened to the language
since 2005 when Avatar Avatar had its
debut well there have been some very
interesting projects that have included
the language uh there's just this
incredibly wonderful Cirque du Soleil
production several years ago based on an
avatar story and it used a surprising
amount of the language uh as visually
utterly stunning
there's now a Disney theme park in
Orlando Florida Pandora the world of
Avatar where if you visit you will you
will encounter some of the cast members
who will speak some Nami to you uh
there's a pamphlet that is handed to you
as a uh as a visitor explaining the
flora and fauna and in the lower left
corner there is
a set of safety instructions that are
bilingual in English and in not me
uh there's an Incredible video game in
the works I'm not sure it's when when
it's I'm not sure when it's going to be
out but I've had the pleasure of working
on it uh but for me uh the most exciting
and rewarding part
of the development of the language has
been the emergence of the lit the
language community of people who have
embraced the language all over the world
and uh really uh have helped me develop
it and uh use the language for genuine
communication some of whose memories are
here today
finally uh I cannot fail to mention the
fact mention the fact that there is now
a sequel Avatar 2
the way of water and it'll be out
only in theaters on December 16th so
with that I'll say irayo
and uh be happy to take some questions
sir
so
um Mark talked about not having expected
language community
[Music]
anticipated that there would be a kind
of community that might emerge so I was
wondering if you could talk about
maybe like considerations the grammar of
the things I doubt it I don't know but
if you think about can you talk more
about what you were thinking about as
you anticipated
yeah well I mean I mean uh
uh Mark was the Pioneer okay and then uh
in
in 2005 to 2009 Klingon was already a
thing and so I I kind of suspected that
there would be some people who would uh
be involved in the language and
uh I mean one of the most astonishing
things
this is kind of unbelievable the movie
first Avatar movie in 2009 in December
came out on a Friday I think it was on a
Thursday the Thursday before I received
an email a long email entirely in Navi
and you can imagine when I my my
reaction I said where the hell did this
come from well uh it turned out that uh
a very early incomplete version of a
glossary had leaked online somehow and I
had been given I've been giving a few
talks to a certain linguistic forums and
groups about the structure of the
language well several people got
together and did their very best to
deconstruct the language and it was
remarkably good it wasn't perfect but it
was remarkably good and um the author of
this uh of this missive Britain Watkins
has some since become a very close
personal friend and he's still very much
involved in the language so so yeah I
mean uh
it's a community that I kind of thought
might develop but uh it's been a very
very rewarding experience for me to
interact with the community
how much did James Cameron affect things
in the bush production
how much did James Cameron affect things
in post-production
um
I guess I would say that the way he
affected things was in his choice of
which take of a certain scene would
appear in the movie
and uh
there were times when the take that I
thought was the absolute best take in
terms of the language because guess what
that's my focus was not necessarily the
take that he would choose because hey
you know the guy's thinking of the
acting the emotion the the the
choreography so to speak the
cinematography everything and there are
a lot of considerations so
um if in fact take that that he chose
wasn't necessarily the one that had the
most perfect language
that was it that was a given and so like
Mark I would sometimes have to adapt the
language to what emergency it didn't
happen very often but uh on occasion it
did
sir
um
I'm sorry I didn't quite get through
could you repeat it
yeah
um I I frankly did not and that that was
more much more Left To the Actors and to
James Cameron that sort of thing I mean
the the ice
was it was a gesture that sort of
emerged which fit in perfectly well with
the language but I didn't I didn't have
anything to do with that
Angela
[Music]
uh
I was very lucky
uh with Avatar in that I got to work
directly with all the actors and it was
great
um and uh there was a fair amount of
coaching involved what I did uh
invariably was provide them with a text
with
uh quote-unquote phonetic transcription
was a quasi-englishy kind of
transcription uh and then with MP3
recordings so they had that preliminary
preliminarily to work on and then I
would always meet with them and uh help
them tweak their pronunciation usually
it worked out pretty well I mean with no
exceptions they all wanted to nail it
you know and you know frankly some had
you know more could have
native Talent than others but it all
came out pretty well okay thanks very
much
great so thank you so much to our four
wonderful call nine creators and I'd
actually like to invite you back up to
sit on the panel because we do have a
few more questions that we'd like to
address to you as a group of panelists
so yeah if you wouldn't mind taking a
seat and grabbing a microphone
foreign
okay so the first question that I would
like to ask the panelists and you could
all sort of take your turn answering it
in whichever order you'd like
um but a lot of these languages were
created either for a different world on
a different planet or for a different
sort of universe that might resemble
Earth but is different in a lot of key
ways and some of these were touched upon
in your talks but
um how did you navigate these instances
of Designing a language that's
that is being used to talk about things
that are very different from the uses of
you know for example English and
everyday life how did you navigate these
how did you come up with words for
situations that don't really occur very
often
um in everyday life for us
I'll say when I worked on a show and by
the way this microphone is purely for
show so but
um when I was working on a show called
Defiance uh that would it took place in
America after aliens had crash landed
here and had lived here for 40 years but
I always found it very handy that these
aliens came from
um came from you know alien worlds when
it came to creating new words because in
English we have a lot of words that were
derived from based on animals and plans
I'm not coming up today where's some
good animal like
I'm thinking about an expression inside
like a fox but like Weasley or to weasel
out of something what are some other
animal ones
yeah yeah things like that and so this
was great because anytime I wanted to
come up with a new word I could just
invent some animal on these planets that
have now been destroyed like we weren't
going to see them again so I mean just
to say that this was based on some
animal that had these particular
characteristics and then they can
actually say something that's great
um for me actually is it was a reverse
problem that was more vexing uh
not be as is a language spoken in a very
special place are very special
human life Creations but how do you
adapt that language to the Earth where
people want to use it in Earth-like
situations so for example I was
mentioning this to a couple of other
people
um
did not be apparently don't have chairs
I've never seen a chair in the movie
video sit on projects
so uh how do you say chair and how
should you say chair enough there was a
contingent early on that said
if this does not exist on Pandora I
don't want to work for it that would
break the purity of the language and the
other group said no we want to use a
language here what I wound up doing is
that particular particular situation is
take the word for sit everybody said
it's including that thing and then add a
morpheme that represented the tool for
Dooms so a chair became a tool system
that sort of thing but but there was
this this soldiers
divert the Divergence on the premium
early on like they were all the people
who wanted to use it here on Earth
[Music]
[Music]
somewhere else
another way is to borrow they could be a
long word but initially initially as I
said it was only the word zillion script
so I didn't have to think about that at
the outset so the the economy that
changed over time though is that if you
looked up the thing on language and
Wikipedia
one of the things they used to say
is the vocabulary of playing that is
very restricted and more ideal for outer
space travel it has been practical
everyday concerns for example there's a
word for bridge like a bridge on it I
don't know
it is very addictive isn't it it just
has a microphone
um I I don't know if it counts as a
version but I do know like one set of
considerations that we've had to deal
with
um and that you've had somewhat as well
because sometimes words were given to
you that you were like well I have to do
something with this in the language
um but we have worked on projects that
were based on books that used entire
sentences of the conlang and so like
having to essentially figure out how it
would make sense for these sentences to
have meanings and what we wanted to do
with the conlang
um which meant sometimes doing some
creative things with like
pulling words apart in ways that you
wouldn't necessarily think about doing
because you you wanted these meaningful
components to work out and so I think
that played a role otherwise version
wise I don't know that we like once we
actually you know send it out to the
actors well we sure hope that's the
final version of based on
um and so I I don't know that there are
any other versions beyond that
um that that we have
I'll just say that the translations by
the end of the first season are usually
a lot better than they are at the
beginning of the first season especially
when we haven't been given a lot of time
for example like that wasn't a joke when
we did uh mini Shay for motherland Port
Salem we had 10 days
um exactly yeah
yeah
version history yeah foreign
versions but there were definitely
things that got sort of tweaked along
the way and I must say that this is one
of the places that the language
Community has helped me I mean I think I
did a pretty a pretty decent job but you
know there are certain things that you
don't anticipate and um
there are times when
I would get a very very polite note
saying
um well you know you you just use this
particular form in a recent blog post
but six years ago in in an earlier post
you said that you couldn't do that and
now you're doing this and my response
was thank you you're absolutely right uh
that that was an uh that was a an
earlier version of the language it it
was a fossilized form which which is no
longer in use and just go by what it
just said
does mine work as well yeah
all right well
uh I would say
that what I've learned
is a result of this conlanging adventure
but going on and some other things too
but just let's talk about Klingon is I
developed a skill called retconning
and I think I think that I've improved
most in that regard uh than in some
linguistic stuff yeah though there's
stuff comes back to haunt
thank you very much um so for the next
question you know one of the themes that
we've been talking about and exploring
today
um and in this department generally is
just the diverse City in human languages
and you know any natural language has a
variety of different dialects different
accents just variation within the
language so how have you managed to take
ideas like that about the diversity
within a language into conline creation
to a very minimal extent we were able to
do that in motherland and that's because
in the final season they wanted an older
form of the language to appear so we
were able to Showcase how it would have
sounded hundreds of years before the
earlier episode so that was exciting and
then we also had in the first season a
situation where non-native speakers were
trying to speak the language and so we
were able to create sort of a a second
language learner version of the language
in terms of like what we thought that
they would get right or what they would
struggle with in the language and so
that was pretty exciting but like we
don't normally get a lot of
opportunities for that however I know
David has on other shows it really
depends on the on the script in the
world uh a lot of times because uh often
especially if what you're essentially
doing is a language for the monster of
the week whether it's in a movie or a
show
um you know you're getting the language
spoken by one maybe two characters who
have pretty much the same background and
are honestly shouting most of the time
so there's just not much opportunity to
showcase a lot of like intra-linguistic
diversity but every so often you get to
and Defiance was a really great project
just a wonderful project that you know
that was snake bit from the time from
the get-go as they were trying to do
like a video game and a show at the same
time and a game by a company that nobody
had heard of all due respect try on
worlds but um but that was really
wonderful because then you had many
different alien languages and you had
adult native speakers who were learning
English as a second language they had
children who grew up bilingual and then
of course there were also human beings
who learned these languages as second
languages and then of course the aliens
themselves learned each other's
languages as second languages either
before they came to Earth or after so
there was a lot of fun to be had there
that was the only uh show that I can
think of where I actually did a lot of
work borrowing words not just from
English into my languages but from my
languages back into English and so there
was there were so many opportunities and
like every episode to do all these
interesting things with different
languages but then it's like you know
then you also have Thor the Dark World
where there were two characters that
spoke it both of them are dead by the
end of it and um and it is there's just
there wasn't an opportunity to do really
anything interesting in that regard
well for Klingon like I could think of
two two kinds of things
one is in um
in Star Trek 6 there is a scene where
they speak a different dialect of
Klingon a lot of people come up to me
why are those actors so bad when they
speak they're not bad they're
intentionally speaking a different
dialect uh and I've talked about and
sketched but not fully developed you
know three or four other dialects so we
know there's dialects around Klingons
are supposed to be the Klingon Empire
they're supposed to be a whole bunch of
folks speaking different languages
different dialects all that stuff so
there's hints about that but again I'm
not a Star Trek writer so I didn't do
much except for say yeah that's true and
here's sort of maybe how it works the
other thing I thought in terms of what
David you made me think of it in terms
of the learning as a second language and
stuff like that
uh when I work with Christopher Plummer
on on Star Trek six he said to me all
right let's work on this Klingon
language a lot he says I should be able
to speak this language really fluidly if
I'm happy because that's my first
language if I'm having trouble with the
language it should be with English his
character his Klingon character I
thought that was exactly the right
approach
the reverse of that was working with
with David Warner
who played a a an earth guy all right he
played a British guy uh in Star Trek
five he only had to say one line in
Klingon actually I think it was even
just one word
in in Klingon and they said okay let's
let's work on it he says now I want you
to teach me how to say it poorly
and and I said why he said us Brits are
notoriously bad at foreign languages
[Laughter]
so uh in Avatar there was very little
linguistic diversity everyone
essentially spoke the same version of
the language uh however there are four
sequels planned one is coming out next
month and uh hopefully there will be
three others and it's certainly not
impossible that at some point in the
franchise we will meet other tribes
other groups of people living on Pandora
who might possibly speak a different
dialect of Navi not impossible
thank you so much for those answers so
for the last question that I'll ask
before we turn it over to a few more
audience questions is could you each
share a phrase in a Kong Lang that you
created uh what that phrase means and
what it means to you and maybe something
interesting about its etymology or
phonology
um for for any comment
uh well the one I always remember that I
really enjoy from from High Valyrian
because it was kind of the Revelation
that Daenerys spoke High Valyrian was
which is uh which was fun because it was
a dragon is not a slave
um but the but I was able to do some fun
things with it because ordinarily uh you
would expect uh this the High Valyrian
word for slave to be used which was
which is I was probably a good thing I
didn't use that one because it has two
trills right after one another she
wouldn't have got that but um but I used
a different word buzzari because it was
it came from uh in the context of the
show it came from old the old ghiscari
language because the version of valerian
that was spoken in slavers Bay uh was
spoken by former gaskari speakers who
had brought in a lot of vocabulary from
their language and so they just used the
kiskari word for slate and so I had I
had Daenerys borrow it in to I Valyrian
for this sentence in particular so that
it would be very clear to the person
that she was talking to the guy who
thought that she didn't speak this
language that not only did she speak
Valerian but she spoke his version of
Valyrian as well and understood
everything he'd been saying because up
until that point he'd just been
insulting her left and right and his
translator had been massaging it for him
and he just assumed that he could get
away with that and she wanted to make
sure that he knew before he got burned
to a crisp that she knew
uh so in many Shea we have the phrase
and that translates as I love you but it
literally means you are my song uh
because the witches have like these
special
powers that are related to what they
call songs or seeds um which are very
powerful things they do with their voice
and so we decided that would be the most
intimate thing you could say to somebody
else if you were a speaker of that
language
uh for Navi I would have to say that uh
it's the sentence I love you which comes
out as literally
uh you beloved are to me and very early
on after the movie came out I got a
request
of uh please write that down for me of
course I want to have a tattooed on my
arm
yeah tattoos are quite a thing um
that's process of
finalizing up for me but for somebody
else this you put it in a movie who
cares you know but put it on your on
your skin
I'm gonna cheat
okay uh and not give a phrase but just
give a word because when I was working
on cling on the on the first film which
is the third film uh I was wondering is
there going to be a word that people are
going to recognize as Klingon even if
you don't know anything about the
language really okay is there going to
be a non-new non-new you know kind of
kind of thing if anyone knows what that
is if you're old enough
um and there is you know and the word is
Kapla which is the which is the word
everyone knows and you go around and
people say crop lie crap it got out
there somehow yeah
success people think it means hello
goodbye or something like that it
doesn't it means success is when you're
going off on a mission yeah
all right thank you so much thank you so
much for sharing those uh now I think we
have time for a couple of audience
questions so if anyone didn't get a
chance to get their question in now is
your chance yes so I'm curious about
language regulation so when you meet
your demise whether uncomfortable
and making sure that the community has
sort of an authoritative Source uh for
new words uh new grammatical
instructions Etc I have a pretty strong
opinion about this so I want to say that
and I and all and I want to say it in
this in this context at um at the the
second language creation conference
which was in 2007 in Berkeley in fact uh
Erica was there uh and that was where he
met the first time uh David Salo came
and spoke there and I was looking things
up and you know he uh worked as the
translator translator for tolkien's
languages for the uh for the films uh
for the Lord of the Rings films and I
found it very disappointing and honestly
just baffling that there was was a
strong and negative reaction within the
Tolkien language Community online
about his work as a translator on the on
the movies because
um not every single word that was used
in the movies were ones that Tolkien had
come up with and and their opinion was
like you can't even call this cindereen
it's not the same thing it's some
bizarre Frankenstein thing and I thought
it was just so ridiculous because
um a language whether it's created or
not a language has two states either
it's alive or it's dead and that's it
and
like at some point in time yeah we're
we're all going to be dead but it's like
basically at that point then what it's
the language is just left and so
honestly the question is uh you know
who's the authority on it well uh I I
this isn't a flipping answer the
question is who cares right and the and
really all you have to do in my opinion
is just tag it it's like all right these
are all the words for example that I
came up with for high Valerian when I
die at some point if some other people
come up with some words like like all
right these are the ones that they came
up with do you like them then use them
do you not like them then don't and
really then it's just like all right
well whatever the language just splits
it I don't think it hurts anything to
have other people come up with words and
it's like if the majority decide they
don't like it then they don't use it but
the same thing happens with the
languages we speak the same thing
happens with English if the majority
don't like the words then they don't get
repeated people don't learn them and
they don't use them it's it doesn't hurt
the English language same thing with
ours I think
I thought we had the understanding I was
the authority overall
things change I guess
uh when it comes to the uh it's a good
question I have not designated any
successors so to speak I mean for better
or worse I'm the gatekeeper I'm the one
who decides what's in what's and what's
not
um
there are a number of people in the not
the language Community who know the
language so well that they could
actually take over how that person would
be chosen or whether it should be a
person or maybe it should be the
equivalent of what someone was talking
about like an academy the not be The
Language Academy that remains to be
determined
I'd say I'd say ditto
yeah yeah same same thing for Klingon uh
the way the way
Klingon is going uh it's the speakers
who are gonna who are going to be these
people this Academy whatever it is what
what what form that takes what the
organization is who's who who's in who's
out
I don't know but they're the ones using
the language they get to deal with it I
don't care you know at that point
all right we have time for one final
question for our panelists let's see who
hasn't gotten a chance to ask a question
yet maybe over there
how did you find yourselves in this line
of work
well mine is perhaps the easiest and
shortest answer I met David
specifically I I ran a competition
because I wanted to work with somebody
to create the language for motherland
Fort Salem and there were a lot of
people that applied and I reviewed their
applications I interviewed five of them
and Jesse was the best and she was
incredible so uh but you also were a
language Creator already she'd been a
language creator for
longer than I had
um for for myself I also came by way of
a competition the language creation
Society put together a competition for
uh to create Dothraki for Game of
Thrones and so I and many other language
creators competed for it and I won it
and and so that was that was that
well no I had to recuse myself
yeah actually the first round was judged
by other language creators the second
round by The Producers it was a flawed
competition we could talk about that
later if we want
uh for me the the very short answer is
that uh there was a job opening I
applied for it and I got it the more
interesting someone's longer answer is
this is back in 2005
um
I have a patient in linguistics but I
was actually teaching at USC in the
business school I was teaching uh in the
uh Center for management communication
uh and I was not I did not have any
direct connection with the Linguistics
Department which is where I got my
degree from but out of some
alignment of the Stars a good friend of
mine in the department a guy named ed
Finnegan who is a former professor of
mine who became a mentor and in fact my
co-author on this linguistic workbook
looking at languages
um he noticed an email that had come to
the Linguistics department at USC where
James Cameron's production company light
storm was looking for a linguist who
could develop a language for a science
fiction film at the time it was known as
project 880. and so it forwarded the
email to me and said you know I think
this kind of sounds like you so I looked
at it and said yeah that definitely
sounds like me so I I applied for the
job I send Cameron um a copy of our
workbook a couple weeks later I get a
call why don't you come in and talk to
Jim
so I had this incredible 90 minutes in
his private office
uh and he told me about his vision for
the language it apparently went pretty
well uh
stood up shook my hand and said welcome
aboard
and my life has not been the same ever
since
well I got I got tapped for Klingon
because I did Vulcan before that uh I
got tapped so that's easy
I got tapped for Vulcan
uh I mean there's a story but the very
short version is luck
um
I had I had some I was I was in LA I had
some spare time which I hadn't counted
on I got together with a friend my
friend happened to be working at
Paramount her boss happened to be harv
Bennett who was a producer of Star Trek
2 uh during lunch they told me they
needed a linguist I thought that was
great go off or not they were going to
hire a linguist from UCLA they had
trouble
linking up with the linguists from UCLA
and they said they needed this done
right away I said how long will you meet
right away we need it done this week
which is how long I was in town I
volunteered and now I'm here
all right thank you so much for your
very insightful question I answers these
questions thank you so much to our
creators
so this concludes our segment with the
Conlan creators and we do have a second
segment with conlang researchers who are
doing language research
um in between we're going to have a
break but during the break there will be
an opportunity to participate in a
trivia game where you can test your
knowledge of three different languages
Esperanto Navi or Klingon so if you are
interested in the trivia you are welcome
to stay here the first call Lang
researcher talk begins at 4 10 which is
in 30 minutes so if you participate in
the trivia that shouldn't take more than
about 15-20 minutes so you will still
have time to get in a break so if you
would like to participate in the trivia
anyone can do it all you need is a
device with an internet connection then
please stay in the room and we'll get
started in just a minute
oh yes there will be prizes for the
winners
and while we're getting started I will
say the prizes well
in order to get the prize you have to
pass two steps so the first step is to
be a finalist from the trivia and then
the top two performers from this trivia
game for each language will then be
asked a question by the creator of that
language except for Esperanto because
that wouldn't be possible
I will be cosplaying examinhoff today
[Music]
um
and then the winner of that question
whoever answers that question first and
that'll be later that'll be after the
researcher talks will then win the the
top prize for that language okay our
raise your hand if you are in the room
for the Esperanto quiz okay I think
that's all the people are gonna get so
we're just gonna get you started and
then we'll do the other two languages in
just a second
okay there are eight 18 people are doing
Esperanto wow 19. okay great so we are
going to get started it will be on your
devices so you do not need to look at
the screen the screen will show the
leaderboard but all the questions will
be on your device okay ready
set
and now we'll get started with Navi
okay so if you would like to join Navi
while the Esperanto players are getting
started please join this uh use this
join code to enter the game room
we can check on the leaderboard for
Esperanto okay
we've got some solid competition going
all right we have seven people in for
Navi
so I think we're just gonna get started
unless anyone needs a minute
oh you need a minute okay okay
we'll get clinged on well yeah in just a
minute we'll get started with Klingon
oh okay
okay in the meantime I can also show the
Klingon trivia so if you want to play
Klingon you can join here I'll split
screen it so that you can see both
Right is coming up uh oh no
which one did I just do yes
left is Navi yep
yeah so join myquiz.com and then enter
these codes the left is for Navi and the
right is for Klingon
okay we have 10 players on the left so
yeah that's that's the navi room and we
have eight players for Klingon does
anyone need a bit more time to join
almost there okay
[Music]
no okay we're gonna have to get started
so
all right we are starting
Navi and
we have questions
yes there are yeah
the questions won't appear on the screen
they you have to join on your device
but I think it's a bit unfair if the
Creator participates in the trivia
though
I'm in the lead
oh
[Music]
thank you
so you might be able to tell from the
names on the leaderboard which language
it is
[Music]
[Music]
what is it
oh they're not in the room oh they're oh
it's a live stream
that's how there's so many players I was
wondering how so many people suddenly
joined
is that allowed do they still get a
prize
okay
some people didn't participate but is
anyone still going
okay so I think we're gonna end the
games
and we have a list of the winners so
we're gonna screenshot that for later so
I'm gonna end these
okay so we will make note of the top two
winners and then after the research
talks we will invite the top two
finalists from each language up to hear
a question from the Conlan Creator
um except for Esperanto
um and then we will still ask a question
it just won't be from the Creator and
then the winner will get a special prize
and the second place will also get a
runner-up prize meanwhile anyone who
participated is welcome to come get a
sticker from our Duolingo sponsor
um who well they sponsored Us in the
sense of sending us these wonderful uh
Duolingo stickers so
okay if you are one of the top two as
shown on this screen could you just step
aside over here so we know who you are
if you're one of the top two players
from the language each language hello
you are Jacob okay but in what is your
username okay great all right okay so
this is uh okay great can I just write
down your yeah names Okay so
so we will now be hearing from a series
of oh thank you of conlang researchers
or language researchers generally they
don't necessarily all exclusively study
con wangs but language generally with
um relevant interests that line up with
constructed languages but first we'll be
hearing um from Damian blasi so Damian
is a postdoctoral researcher at the
culture cognition and co-evolution lab
at Harvard just up the street
um and a Harvard data science initiative
fellow he studies the relationship
between human cognition and linguistic
diversity with interests that include
the emergence of new languages and
cross-linguistic patterns so uh Damian's
hopefully gonna have some very
insightful things to say as it pertains
to constructed languages so without
further Ado we're very much looking
forward to your talk thank you so much
and thanks so much Simon uh Elise EV
this has been amazing I mean this I
would say from the last two years it has
been the most cool conference I've been
to so thanks a lot and and it's a total
order right because from now we're it's
going to be like I don't expect what you
just seen and I I am the least cool of
all of you because I am the only one who
actually hasn't done any research on
conlangs I work on linguistic diversity
uh uh broadly defined and you'll see
what I'm what I'm talking about
um so and I just want to situate you a
little bit on the type of research and
the the science I produced and I have to
say that whatever I do hasn't been
possible because it it just it became
possible because of developments in the
last 20 years and there's three very
important factors that have played out
in the way in which me and others study
the languages of the world so first of
all we have now massive amounts of
digitalized data from many different
languages we have speech samples we have
Wikipedia dumps we have corpora from
many many different languages that we
didn't have access to just as I said 10
20 years back second we have uh and
consequence a number of computational
methods that allow us to take all of
that mass of data and learn and make
inferences about the languages of the
world and finally and to my mind slash
heart this is the most important
component of the this approach the
linguistic diversity which is it's very
interdisciplinary so the study of
linguistic diversity is not anymore the
private Turf of linguists now they are
evolutionary biologists they are
anthropologists cognitive
neuroscientists and a long long Etc so
uh it's very exciting we're still trying
to come up with a common vocabulary
about how to talk all these things and I
I hope you'll see some of this in the
next few slides and what I'm going to do
is I will tell you you some I'm going to
be glossing over all details of course
but I'm going to be telling you about
some findings that I think are ask us to
rethink what we think is the design
space of language and because I'm very
narcissistic I'm going to cite my own
work but there's a lot of excellent work
by much better people than me but still
this is representative so let's start
with something very straightforward if
you ever get to open a Linguistics 101
textbook at some point you're going to
find this claim that there is no
necessary connection between how you
name something and the thing itself it
doesn't matter how you call a bird water
dog whatever it's just a convention and
there's nothing necessary about how you
call it and of course this is trivially
true we can just come up with a new
language and we can use any uh word or
name that we want for that that's
perfectly fine but I think the the true
underlying question here is not whether
languages can have this arbitrary
relation between form and meaning by
whether there actually are and
historically what happened is that you
know a linguists will go check a bunch
of different words from different
languages for the same referent like in
this case where you have no's in nine
different languages you take a look
around and say well actually there
doesn't seem to be anything in common
between those so there's nothing really
going on but once you are able through
computational methods to ask more
precise questions about subtle
patterning between form and meaning you
end up finding a bunch of different very
clear emerging uh uh results and you
know I'm I just knows because I know
it's no nasal consonants it makes sense
and some people have uh proposed that
this makes sense indeed but uh we have
studied a large number of words in basic
vocabulary in many different languages
and we find that in about 50 of all the
hundreds of words that we have studied
we find robust convergence in form and
meaning so even if human languages can
be abs totally arbitrary when it comes
to four meaning associations they are
not most of the time
then there is something that is perhaps
a bit more Arcane but it's very close to
my heart and this is to do with this
idea that has been going on for 150
years that there is there has been no
substantive change in the nature of
languages now in relation to the past so
if you know you look around languages
there are relative clauses the terminers
labyrinthals uh whatever you name it
then there's no good reason to think
that any of those things were absent in
the past or that there's stuff that
existed in the past and doesn't exist
now so there's a bit of a continuity now
for anyone who has done any research on
any aspect of humans for more than you
know five years or something like that
if you look at the long scale of time
you I mean one very obvious thing is
that humans have changed dramatically
and you know I'm singling now they are
the Holocene which this period of time
the last 12 000 years where we went from
being living in small hand together
societies eating mostly food that was
available to living in huge Urban setups
and human biology human culture human
morality have changed enormously but we
still have this assumption that
languages actually have remained exactly
the same at least in this broad
description
now I think at this point we have enough
evidence to uh to realize that this is
not true let me give you a very
superficial uh uh demonstration of that
and one very well established change uh
that palanthropologists have uh
established in this period of time the
Holocene is that there has been a global
and asynchronous change in the shape of
the human bite so if you go if you ever
go to a natural history museum and you
see human remains from the early
Holocene you'll see that the bite is
such that upper teeth and lower teeth
are in a perfect occlusion now I guess
most of us here in this audience you're
going to find that the upper teeth your
upper teeth produce an angle in relation
to your lower teeth and you might ask
okay yeah that's nice but who cares and
the things that you might not care but
if you want to produce a lady Dental
sound which in English are sounds like f
and V this makes a world of difference
and again I'm not giving you any of the
details but in our study we have linked
these changes in human byte over the
last 12 000 years to what I think it's a
pretty impressive finding which is that
most likely 12 000 years back no human
languages have low rentals The Sounds F
and B didn't exist but now this speech
sounds are present in about half of the
world's languages so there has been a
dramatic change in what we can or we can
expect around the languages of the world
um then
um something more
um
something that links language with the
broader human spectrum and I think we
have learned Lots about this in the last
10 years there has been a lot of study
on how is that languages are being
co-transmitted with aspects of culture
and also with aspects of human biology
including the genomes and there is this
well-established finding from the 90s
that if you look at the history of
different populations from the point of
view of genetics and you compare that
with the linguistic history of
populations they're pretty much the same
there is a bit of a mirror situation and
most of the initial papers that
establish that relation were strongly
based in Europe and Erasure more in
general but more recently and well
something happened with that fund what
was that wow um so
um in a few weeks you're going to see a
paper where we take a much broader
sample of languages and genomes of
populations of the world and what we
find is that actually the European and
narration case was success and most of
the time in most of History even before
European colonialism languages and genes
going perfectly independent ways so
people mingle together sometimes the
past languages sometimes genes sometimes
both sometimes none so it seems that
chaos has been the guiding force of the
evolution of languages and genomes in
this regard okay so I I'm really hopeful
that we'll keep finding very cool
um aspects of language that speak
directly to what a language is but there
is also reason to be a bit cautious in
the sense that most of the the most well
studied languages are very few I'm using
a figure of 100 here and being super
optimistic like anyone has done any real
research or language knows that I'm I'm
being super super optimistic here but we
should keep in mind that there is about
7 000 languages out there and one very
important thing to mention is that there
is also a practical side to increase
seeing the representation and the data
and the studies of languages beyond the
handful of languages I have been studied
very well so most obvious of those have
to do for instance with the fact that if
you have more data for more languages
it's easier to come up with more
efficient language Technologies which
are fundamental in most contemporary
societies think about speech recognition
think about machine translation etc etc
I don't think you'll be surprised if I
told you that still to this day most
development in language Technologies are
monopolized by just 20 languages and it
doesn't seem to be a lot of evidence
that this is going to change rapidly for
the next few years
now there is another reason that again
it I I shouldn't use this expression
close to my heart twice in the talk I
someone told me that many years back and
now I'm doing it okay but there's
another reason that I think it's
extremely important and for that I need
to refer to this problem that has become
very fashionable in the last 10 years
and that has to do with the observation
that when we think about the subjects
that have been the base of our science
of human behavior and human cognition we
are not just sampling randomly from the
humans that exist in the world but
instead we're picking on a very specific
type of human in particular undergrads
in in wealthy uh universities so and and
uh and um this individuals belong to
societies are Western educated
industrialized rich and Democratic hence
the acronym weird
um and this is a big problem because
it's not just they come from a
particular type of society but there is
very reliably consequences of growing up
in such society and all all sorts of
aspects of a human mind like your moral
judgments how you categorize things even
how you interact with visual Illusions
now I think you know where I'm going
with this
um yes not only most humans they're
having a study in Psychology and
Behavioral Sciences come from weird
societies but they also most of the time
speak English and again as there is a
strong important difference in the type
of societies that we're societies are in
relation to other societies there's
important differences in English when
you compare English with all languages
of the world and and I think now it's
it's reasonable to ask well if we're
societies have an effect and might
compromise our capacity to generalize
findings Beyond uh
humans that belong to societies can we
make the same inference in relation to
speakers of English and this has been a
very controversial topic but more
recently my collaborators and I had the
opinion that in 2022 there is enough
evidence to suggest that there is a
non-trivial connection between at least
certain aspects of cognition and the
language one science or speaks of course
it doesn't determine how you think or
anything like that some effects are very
Supple and very small but they are there
now I know that I I should have like
you're handling that one minute I would
say it's one minute and 30. clearly the
the the takeaway message is very
straightforward if we really want to
have a science of human cognition and
human behavior that truly encompasses
all humans and we have to take into
account the fact that there are all
those languages are there now very
briefly I want to say this super briefly
like okay what three minutes oh oh wow I
was about to rush wow wow all right I'll
just drink some water I wish I was
rushing wow
all right
um so I have a story this something like
this happened in a job interview like
yeah which was terrible now it's we're
it's all laughs it's great
um so this is thing that even if we are
extremely optimistic and we managed to
get data and Analysis and studies with
all seven thousand languages out there
there's still something we are missing
and I know this is a poorly defined
concept just go with me with this
um we are missing the space of possible
languages in other languages that happen
to exist but languages that could have
existed and could have happily exist as
natural languages
and I guess you know where I'm going
with this if if you agree with us on
that the relation between language and
cognition and maybe other aspects of
behavior is non-trivial there is
something going on there then looking at
this possible languages are very far
from the languages we know is extremely
interesting and a very important step
forward in understanding what means to
be a human or to have a human cognition
so
um if you haven't read
um
this amazing book will just be hearing
more about you should but there is a lot
great I see that I'm going through my
autograph immediately after I stop with
my presentation but what's going to say
is that in the colon Community there
have been many attempts of coming up
with languages are explicitly engineered
in order to produce a specific cognitive
result or testing hypothesis about how
humans things Etc et cetera and I think
the motivation is great it aligns
perfectly with the way we think
um but there's a number of technical uh
problems with the approaches it seems
that most of the outcomes of this
conlang experiments that aim at testing
the relation between language and
cognition have been limited a bit by the
lack of uh proper experimental designs
and way of keeping track of information
or learning etc etc this is boring but
I'm just putting this because I think
one of the most interesting outcomes
apart from the main study that we are
running here or they are running here is
that I will love that we get to talk
more that we people working with
languages and thinking of very different
languages get to talk with conlang
creators so that's it thank you wow that
that's uh it was a beautiful I spent so
much time choosing the font but anyhow
yeah thank you thanks so much
[Applause]
and it's Ariel you know if it was
verdana or something like that but it's
just horrible
so I have a question about like so you
said that there's evidence that
languages can possibly consumers
implantation but how do you distinguish
between
languages themselves influencing areas
of cognition versus that which is
culturally transmitted through languages
because it seems like the vast majority
of cultural transmission happens within
languages for the simple reason that
you know if you speak a language you
have access to the great you know fire
hose of everything said and written and
so on in it whereas if you don't then
you only have access to the relative
triple that is translated so again so
how do you distinguish you know that
influence of a language itself
yeah
it was just culturally using the
language
this is a this is a very very difficult
question and in many cases we are unable
to extinguish between the two right you
as always mentioned before you don't
receive just your language in isolation
you get Norms culture beliefs even genes
in some situations so sometimes there is
it's absolutely impossible to tell one
from the other I think that what what
one could do though is to increase the
feasibility of a given account so if I'm
telling you that there is a particular
aspect of a language that has a specific
cognitive effect that is possible in the
context of what we know in cognitive
science then you're doing well there
doesn't mean that it's going to be right
but I think that's that's a Way Forward
I I am I regulating this I have to
decide no don't make me decide please I
feel like guilty it's like who was first
there
whoever was first yes okay
um how much thinking thinking has your
research team done about the idea of an
optimal language for human functioning
uh as an example let us say that uh
being able to uh perform well in
advanced physics is a very admirable
human trait something that would
encourage that sort of thinking
maximally while under the constraint
that they still can function with
everyday things in a relaxed manner I
mean is that how much have you thought
about things like that
I I
work on the
description and the understanding of
these patterns but the engineering part
that is a completely different monster
and I want to be very cautious uh before
saying anything that has to do with uh
um what I think would it yeah
thank you
[Laughter]
yep
also you said that about 7 000 languages
or so when you're talking about that
most of it are dialogues or refugees and
where do you draw the one
excellent
um so we are right now I'm working with
uh UNESCO with the United Nations uh and
we are trying to come up with a way of
having some type of rule to determine
the difference between a language
variety and uh and it's a very hard
problem I was talking with some of you
before that you might think this is just
an innocuous decision it's like oh you
know if there is I mean sometimes people
throw the rule 70 in eligibility which
what does it mean on which set of
communicative intentions right it
doesn't make a lot of sense now
you might think you can just use any of
those rules but in actuality what
happens is that those decisions end up
having an impact on on people's rights
sometimes like for instance there are
some governments that provide specific
funds to speakers of a small minority
languages so what happens if you're just
speaking a a big language or you're just
a very special variety of that big
language so we don't know the difference
between dialect and and language is one
of those that it's not entirely
scientific and it keeps coming up I I
would like to understand better why is
it so appealing yeah
I I yeah you
know amongst the set of possible
languages is a very small subset of
useless languages which is always
something that's interested because
there are languages for example every
language that I know of has been
designed to be useful uh even the ones
that we speak uh are you know
unconsciously designed to be useful but
even something like this coil was
designed to be useful so I'll give you
an example of a theoretical language
that has a real
feature so like languages will
distinguish like singular from plural or
singular from Dual from plural some may
be singular from trial plural but there
is a possible language that
distinguishes singular from plural but
has a very special morphological form
for exactly 17 of something
well and perhaps it's a very irregular
form and I always wondered well if you
first first the purposes of
experimentation if you design these
really useless languages or languages
with really useless features what would
it mean to learn that and like could
they even be retained along without
being eroded well so
I would say that most sorry uh most most
I I don't know how to regulate this most
natural languages are um
are full of garbage there's a lot of
stuff seriously there is a lot of stuff
about natural languages that is not
really playing a very active functional
role and and we humans are ex of course
I'm a human so what do you expect you
know we humans are extremely smart
animals we can learn very complicated
systems that might not be extremely
optimized for doing exactly the task and
many times you might just conserve a
bunch of these markers that might just
have lost all other function because
they provide you with you know social
signaling or because you're a smart
human you learn it and it's stay there
so I'm sure that we can produce
languages that are much worse than
having a specific marking for 17 and
still my prediction is we are going to
thrive
um
language are you looking at more
specific levels of comprehension so I'm
thinking about there's been a lot of
money
by the Welsh government into schools to
have kids that maybe stay closure at
home also be learning Welsh and schools
so therefore there are four Welsh
speakers in general so you're looking at
difference of like someone who always
speaks the language at home and then
maybe speak something else for everyday
life someone who speaks it at home and
also learning it at school and using an
everyday life and then someone who is
just picking up the line
with maybe like I took Spanish and high
school I didn't speak Spanish at home
are you looking at
those different levels of comprehension
when you're looking at speaker or is
that just going to be
going to be quite messy
so I have to confess something that is
most of my research is observational
like I I got into the study of
linguistic diversity by just essentially
approaching beautiful data sets that
other languages have put together and
it's like I've always only very recently
I think like four years back that I got
into a laboratory and um you know start
playing around with experiments but
um yeah but in a few years hopefully
I'll be able to tell you something more
okay thanks so much thank you
foreign
[Applause]
for that really fascinating look at
linguistic diversity
um so next up we have Erica okrent who
is a linguist and a writer whose book
was just featured uh in dangyan's talk
as well
um so she's the author of in the land of
invented languages which is all about
conlangs the history of constructed
languages as well as being the author of
numerous articles for both scientific
and popular audiences about language and
related topics so without further Ado uh
Erica thank you so much
foreign
it's so great to be here it's great to
be anywhere I'm so glad we can go places
again and and so yeah it was definitely
yeah I'm up for it like invite me
somewhere I'll go
um that uh yeah it's great to be here
and this is such an interesting kind of
Full Circle moment for me personally my
contribution here is the I the history
of invented languages that's my research
here and um
I realized being here that I started
this project in Earnest 20 years ago the
book came out you know it took me a
while and then what came out but
um it was while I was working on my
dissertation and I was procrastinating
and didn't want to work on that I wanted
to flip through books in the library and
read about all these projects and what
happened with them
but my dissertation was an fmri
experiment and I didn't continue along
that path I mean it was a boring it was
about English verbs you know just plain
old vanilla language
but that's where I you know I I did this
fmri experiment and at the time
I couldn't have no one could ever have
imagined that there would be any place
for Esperanto in there or Klingon I'm
that would have been considered
ridiculous ridiculous proposition
um
and uh another part of this 20-year
Circle when I did start in Earnest is
because I came to a Esperanto Congress
the North American Esperanto conference
whatever was here at MIT an Mist student
had organized it and that was my first
contact with like a living constructed
language community and and now I'm here
and there's an fmri experiment and it's
and it's strange and that um at that
event uh I was I had studied a little I
was in the first talk or whatever in the
room and I looked over and I saw a
professor for my Linguistics Department
I guess is that is that yeah that's
Howie Aaron said it was like the
Georgian professor and um I had no idea
that he was an esperantist and and he
wasn't
um
trying to hide it or anything it was
just it wasn't something we talked about
in linguistics it wasn't something that
linguists were uh curious about or
interested in it scientifically and at
this time the second half of the 20th
century Linguistics was doing a lot it
was a little insecure about being a
science and was very you know we're not
talking about that that is kind of
insulting that you even bring it up
because it'd be kind of like if you're
an astronomer or something and then
someone marches into the room like you
know I think if the world were flat
things would work a lot better don't you
think and then you know everyone turns
to look at them and uh you know how very
Dare You We Are Scientists here and what
are you trying to do and that was kind
of the reaction to invented languages in
linguistics
um but even before even when even when
we weren't trying to be a scientist and
it was you know solidly in Humanities
there was again this kind of insults to
bringing up invented languages in the
field uh and when I went and bought a
copy of the Klingon dictionary at the
bookstore I handed it over to the clerk
and they picked it up and looked at it
and said
uh I hate the fact that this exists and
it was this feeling of like insulting
language like to the fact that this
exists in a bookstore where we have
literature and beauty and history and
there's like this is an insult uh and
that that was the attitude about
invented languages but that has changed
a lot and this history of invented
languages has gone on since the book
came out and and has things have really
changed
um so it's interesting for me to work
look look at and I'm gonna go through
kind of quickly go through the history
of invented languages to get us to where
we are today
um with some words from languages so the
first one that we have documentation for
I'm pretty sure people have been doing
this for as long as have they've had the
idea that we're what we're doing is
language humans are natural uh Engineers
they want to make things more optimal
make things better I'm sure people have
been inventing languages longer than
this but the first documentation we have
is of the linguaignota of Hildegard of
bingen from the 12th century and this is
a word from her language
and it means earwax which is strange
because people you know she is was this
a secret language for her nuns was it
something spiritual was it something
metaphysical and it seems from the
vocabulary that she made it was really
her way of just making the world in the
way she wanted to see it it's got word
for earwax it's got word for saucepan
and jokester and barley and really quote
things in her world she wanted to make a
vocabulary that felt right to her
then we don't know why we don't have
documentation about her purposes or
anything like that but to me looking at
it now this looks like an artistic
conling
that's the first one we have evidence
for and then we have various things
happening after that but it doesn't
really pick up again until the 17th
century we get a new age of language
invention with with a very particular
kind of purpose this what had happened
in the Years leading up to this was the
invention of
mathematical notation which was it's it
seems it's such a normal part of our
world now but people used to do
mathematical explanation in blocks of
text if you look at the the old
mathematical
works are like blocks of Latin text
explaining take this from that and
intersect this with that and it's very
hard to follow it's it's confusing and
the the invention of mathematical
notation made it clearer that like now
here comes the invention of calculus
like everything was opened up by this
and it also made it seem it's Universal
right you don't have to doesn't matter
what your language is or spoken
languages you can mathematic notation
works for everybody so people got the
idea like well let's do that for
everything and a whole bunch of
languages come out based on uh numbers
or this idea that we could kind of put
all Concepts into a math of some kind
and then we could see the truth of
everything if we just get the notation
right and so this is one universal
character from cave Beck from 1657 and
what he did was assign a number to every
idea every concept but it's all in
alphabetical order so it's like one
abandon two Abate three abash you know
um which um which means he could get a
sentence like honor thy father and
mother
you could speak it this would be
pronounced
um so uh you can see it's got the P
stands for personal noun uh the f is
like the female version of the personal
noun so so all you need is that one
number it's got a little bit of breaking
down of Concepts but you can't do
operations with this like if you can't
add these numbers together you can't do
anything with these numbers they're it's
not a system that operates in any way
um but this idea really took hold and
there were many attempts uh at this kind
of language
and uh they didn't go very far until uh
a real character in philosophical
language of 1668 this was John uh
Wilkins and
um this word is this is the word for
[ __ ] in that language
um because I had a dictionary and what
word are you gonna look up first
and it's in there because everything in
the universe is in there because what
you need to speak the truth and have all
Concepts broken down into language is a
sense of where everything is in this
system and he where the the pithofo
sansen you couldn't do anything
operational with that wasn't a system
this is a system so SE the beginning of
the word puts you in the the ideas of
actions of motion the P gets you to
motions of purgation
uh the the rest of it takes you through
this chart so you get the pergate the
purgative Motions they can either be
Vapors and windy or wateris or Cirrus
and watery and then you go down to where
are they coming from oh the consistent
growth parts from the guts upward or
downward
and so though each letter there gets you
for further down the tree
until you get to the word for [ __ ] and
all its 17th century
um you know synonyms
um but so this this is an amazing piece
of systematic work but it's really
impossible to use I think maybe a couple
letters were written in it
um but it's it's to say anything in this
language you first have to know exactly
what you want to say and we do not speak
like that we don't know exactly what we
want to say before we start
um so but this was
um the most elaborated version of this
kind of language and this kind of thing
continued on this is from Ruggles in
American universal language of 1829 and
we're still doing this in 1829
um where each letter stands for a part
of this meaning here I don't know how
you pronounce this but um
but you know this idea wouldn't wouldn't
go away
um but and until uh we get to the next
phase in the history which is so now
we're in 1829 now it's the 19th century
and things are changing we've got people
are moving around on the locomotive
engine and there's great nations are are
dissolving a long language lines and
um people want to be able to communicate
enough of this philosophical stuff where
we try to get the meaning of everything
into a word we need to talk to each
other
uh and this brings us to Esperanto which
wasn't the first of this kind but it's
the most successful of its kind and it's
it's the most successful of all the
kinds um because it's still around
people speak it quite naturally they do
everything in it there are native
speakers of it it's a living language
um and the idea here is that you you
make it as easy to learn and and as
regular as possible so me amas I love me
estas I am me parolas I speak Mi dankas
I thank me have us I have and you know
you got a little bit of English you've
got a little bit of uh romance you got a
little bit of you know different Roots
um together to make it you know a little
more fair for for people
um and then you've got the same ending
it's always us the present tense and it
doesn't change with whether it's me or V
or she or Lee it's always the same you
don't have to memorize has all these
irregular verbs and this takes off
and becomes something that people use
now the the first uh type of language
the the Wilkins language was you know
the king the Royal Society was working
on this they people of prestige and of
in high places were interested in this
idea but by the time we got to this one
it was done and anyone doing it was a
nut job
um with Esperanto in those years again
it started off very
um a respectable prestigious thing to do
the League of Nations was interested
after World War One like this might
solve some of these problems let's look
into it
um but eventually uh it became uh
something that only eccentrics did
uh but that's fine it was they're still
doing it uh and using it to do
everything
um
so
there's been this kind of up and down in
invented languages of uh interesting
idea Prestige and then falling off into
like only people who are really into it
still doing it and actually but but
Esperanto was different in that people
were actually living it and that's why
it's still around today
um then uh then we took a little
backwards once Esperanto got to the
point where people thought oh this is
very eccentric this is very strange
there was a uh back to this idea like we
need to be respectable we need to have
something scientific and logeban or log
Lan which was the original version comes
about which was a scientific experiment
teach people a logical language see if
they think more logically and here's the
word for and in logeban because
um because you know there's a lot of
different ways to say and as a logical
connector so you have e which is like
two uh propositions happened so um that
like
John and Alice carried the piano means
maybe they did it one did it in 1930 one
did it in 1912. I'm not saying anything
more than that I'm just asserting two
propositions
um compared with joy which is like they
formed a joint entity and carried the
piano so you have to know exactly which
and you mean and we're kind of back in
that same position of like gotta know
exactly what you mean before you can say
anything
um but people do actually speak this
language it goes very slowly
um but it's possible
uh and then we move to Klingon this is a
line from Hamlet I think you can tell
which one
um and now there's no more of this idea
of grabbing at Prestige or respect it's
it's doing it because it's interesting
and doing it because it's fun and if you
do that people will still come to it and
speak it this is uh a one of the kippas
there I'm over there and you probably
recognize some people in this but this
brings about a new kind of Freedom with
respect to invented language no more of
this fighting for League of Nations to
listen to me it's this is what we're
doing and you can be far more successful
with that uh
and this is serious then we move to the
uh this is a picture from the language
creation Society
yeah you're in there dude
I mean this picture too yeah yeah okay
so and this that now people are doing it
for as an art form doing it for its own
sake and you can still get people to
come and grow it and use it so that is
where the history of invented languages
leads to and then that's where the book
ends
and this has happened all since the end
of that history and it's still going
forward and people are still using these
languages until we get to
now this incredible uh this incredible
idea that they're doing an fmri research
experiment and linguists are teaching
classes in their colleges about invented
languages we went to that from this
um you know no one wants to hear this
hiding in their hiding that you even
speak Esperanto not telling your
department about it to the the point
where it's now something you can use for
Science and use at this prestigious
level without giving up the freedom of
saying hey I'm doing this because I like
it it doesn't have to be useful for
anything but it can still be useful so
sorry all right that's it
[Applause]
yeah
um so we're here
we talked a lot about how you can
measure the sex sex yeah
um
um well I think you know if people are
actually using it that's a big that's a
big step at most of the invented
languages throughout history no one has
ever used even the inventor has never
used it
um so uh success can be anyone using it
or
or it meets your artistic feeling you
know that I just this is what I imagine
I would like a language to be and you've
created it and it satisfies your inner
aesthetic sense that's a that's a type
of success too
um
I should say I I I forgot to get to this
but um having uh uh David and Jesse's
talk about collaborative conlanging
because the history of invented
languages is all individual
megalomaniacs doing it
to to and and to think that it could
then end up at a spot where you could
actually have conling collaboration
where you could build something with
someone else for a purpose that will
then go on to do something and be a
success in a world that you know a few
people know about or a big subculture
knows about it doesn't really matter but
it's been creative and it's working and
it's going that's a success yeah
huh
based on your research what do you think
are the constructive languages that have
the most speakers currently after
Esperanto after Esperanto
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah Esperanto
um
yeah it's it's hard to say because then
it's like well what counts as a speaker
and Esperanto has the advantage of of
living in the real world in a lot of
places uh and there's and there's in
person Gathering a lot of in-person
gatherings and I have seen the in-person
Gatherings for a few for Klingon and for
logeban
um and uh and and then I I hesitate
because like I don't know it's probably
happening for Valyrian and Dothraki and
I I now I'm just I'm I I'm doing the
thing that I started 20 years ago and
I'm not keeping up with it so I'm not
sure but um but yeah it doesn't have to
be a competition
[Laughter]
all set okay great thank you
all right I hope it's not um too late in
the day for um Neuroscience but uh I
hope um you guys will enjoy learning a
little about what we do so
um and there is drinks afterwards so
that's something to look forward to all
right
so um I'm gonna start by just thanking
everybody who made this event possible
This was um put together relatively uh
quickly so uh thank you very much to um
our McGovern Institute uh first and
foremost Elise malvichini who just has
been incredible she's I don't know if
she's still around somewhere
um but she was really great and our
director Bob DeSimone who of course uh
financially supported a lot of this
event and Steve Shannon who makes who is
our operations manager who makes the
scanners work all the time which is
Quite a feat on trying to scan 50 people
in a weekend which is it's it's crazy
it's like certifiably crazy then thanks
to all of our
um uh wonderful lab team from our lab
and from our sister lab Ted lab that
Gibson's lab
this has been a tremendous effort that
can only happen as a communal
effort uh of course our wonderful
conlang creators for coming and speaking
to us but also for helping us with the
experimental materials which make the
research possible because I'm not I
don't speak on links Simon does a little
somewhat she's like no well I don't know
more than me
um and the Duolingo team who also helped
create testing materials and also are
sponsoring the prizes for the trivia
games and our other wonderful speakers
so let's just give them all around
[Applause]
okay so some Basics how can we learn
about how our brains are organized we
have this massive cells a clump of cells
inside our skulls how do we study those
things there's two main approaches that
we have for studying human brains
there's a lot more for studying animal
brains but with humans there's these two
main things one is a method that has
been used for centuries and it's
basically to look at the cognition or
behavior of people who have sustained
some brain damage so you're basically
trying to see whether damage to
particular parts of the brain leads to
particular kinds of problems okay and
this is a this approach is what led us
uh initially figure out that language
lives in the left side of the brain so
in most of you here we don't know if all
of you some of you may be atypically
lateralized but in most of you your
language is in the left half of your
brain and we'll learn this because
damaging your left hemisphere but not
your right leads to language problems
the other approach um is relatively more
recent and that is functional brain
Imaging it's most widely used form and
the form that we use for research um
this weekend a functional MRI only
became available in the 90s and was
developed here in Boston at Mass General
Hospital
and using this approach we can examine
activity in Healthy Living brains and
this is very very cool a lot of cool
things kind of came together to make
this approach um work uh and um using it
we can see which brain areas respond to
which tasks much like we were doing this
weekend by seeing which parts of your
brain are active when you're processing
conlings
all right
so
um
how can we uh so we can ask right what
brain areas respond to national language
so how can we find areas in the brain
that care about language so we can have
you read or listen to sentences much
like a lot of you we're already doing or
we'll do
um tomorrow or on Sunday and we can look
for parts of your brain that respond
more when you process language like real
sentences that have structure and
meaning compared to some stimuli that
looks similar or sounds similar but you
can't quite get anything out of them
right they kind of sound like nonsense
strings
and we call these uh tasks language
localizer tests because they help us
localize or find the language system in
your brains and then we can ask
questions about how that system works
um
here are language systems of six
individual participants this is showing
you
um a lateral side view of the left side
so if you'd like took away my skull
right now that's well you wouldn't see
the activity but you would see that view
and you can see that and like I said in
most individuals the system lives in the
left hemisphere and you can see that the
language system basically consists of a
few different areas so these are areas
that are more active for language versus
these control stimuli and there's some
stuff in the frontal lobe in the front
of the head and on the lateral kind of
side surface here okay
so what are some of the features that
the system has and this is kind of
research over the last few decades some
things we've learned so one is that the
system supports both understanding and
production uh so when we listen to
language or read language or watch
somebody sign if we're understanding
somebody who is speaking a sign language
and similarly when we produce language
either through speaking writing or
signing so in that sense there is kind
of modality Independence in both
understanding and production and these
features together suggest that what the
system is probably doing in some way is
storing our language knowledge right so
some mappings between forms like Words
constructions and meanings what these
things refer to in the world and of
course we use these knowledge
representations to both take some
thought and make it into a string of
words so I can tell you what I'm
thinking and I can also hear you say
some string of words and I can kind of
decode meaning from that right
okay another property that I already
alluded to is that the system seems to
be critically important for language so
that if you um have damage to parts of
the system uh you will have problems in
understanding language in producing
language or both and that can happen as
a result of a stroke some of you may
have relatives like grandmas and
grandpas who have Aphasia as a result of
damage to some parts of the system
and interestingly this only happens if
you sustain damage in adulthood so early
damage if you have a stroke or head
trauma as a kid you will often grow up
and have very little consequences and
that is because our brains when young
are quite flexible much less so later on
sadly
um okay and then
um another relatively recent finding
from our group is that it appears that
the neural infrastructure for language
is quite similar across uh relatively
diverse languages so remember I showed
you some pictures of language system so
this is one of them this is is a brain
of a native speaker of English listening
or reading English
and in fact most of what we know about
processing language in the brain comes
from the study of native English
speakers
you know if you look in the literature
there is a body of work looking at
Germans you know basically countries
where there is money to do expensive
research right so there's German there's
Dutch there's an MPI Max Planck
Institute in the Netherlands there's
some work on French Spanish Mandarin and
a few others but the list very quickly
dwindles and oftentimes there is not a
single study that you can find even
clinical studies for even pretty
languages are spoken by quite a few
people and like Damian told us there's
about 7 000 languages spoken and signed
across the world so do they all look the
same especially given that English is
not quite a typical language right it's
it's strange in all sorts of ways it has
for example more strict word order than
most languages do so does it still look
the same in terms of
um its neural substrates and um Sima did
this work
um just the paper just came out this
year where she showed that the language
system looks similar across 45 different
languages now this is still a teeny
teeny fraction of
the 7000 but it's a much bigger step
than what we've known before
and this is going to be an ongoing
effort in the coming year Simon has a
long career in front of her
um and by making languages language
localizers available to other
researchers we're hoping that this will
encourage others to look at a broader
range of languages as well as to for
example examine properties that are not
present in most languages certainly not
in English right there's many many cool
properties that diverse languages have
all right so now let's go back to
thinking about language more broadly so
I told you that in these language areas
schematically shown in red there's a
strong response kind of by definition
here to language more so than to these
kind of control stimuli and I want you
to think with me what is it that why is
it that language elicits the strong
response what is it about language that
these areas like we've talked about a
lot of different components of language
today right there's many features that
language has
um and um I hope some of you have some
of these in your head but I'll like walk
you through them a little bit right so
you may be thinking maybe it's the
structure of language language is a
highly structured stimulus there's all
sorts of constraints for how words can
go together into phrases and sentences
maybe it's meaning right after all we
use language to communicate meaningful
messages to each other
maybe it's reasoning because oftentimes
when we hear linguistic information that
leads us to build complex causal chains
about events in the world right there's
a lot of kind of thought that may follow
maybe specifically social reasoning
after all all of the time when we hear
somebody say something we're trying to
understand why are they saying this what
do they want me to know or do in
response to their statement
but also linguistic messages are
communicative signals so maybe it's just
they're very communicative nature that
leads to the strong response so over the
last decade or so
um our group has tested these various
ideas and it turns out that none of them
are actually right and I'll tell you why
okay so how do you test these ideas well
you can look at the response in these
language responsive areas to stimuli
that are not language but share these
various features right so you can look
at music and say music is a very
structured stimulus does it elicit any
response in these language areas and it
turns out it doesn't it loads on a
totally different system in your brain
you can look at meaningful stimuli like
pictures or videos of events or objects
in the world and see how the language
system responds to those it turns out
the response is low to those as well
you can get people to do complicated
things right ask them to solve some
logical puzzles or do math in the
scanner or you know predict chess moves
or whatever right some kind of complex
reasoning task or specifically reason
about others Minds Rebecca sex in our
department has been studying A system
that um uh specializes for understanding
what other people think and it turns out
that neither of these things activate
the language system
and you can also examine a wide range of
communicative signals like facial
expressions or body language or even
gestures and it turns out that in the in
the absence of the linguistic signal all
of these stimuli elicit a very low
response in the language areas so in
other words these language responsive
areas appear to be highly highly
selective for language they respond to
something specifically linguistic about
the structure or about linguistic
meaning
and another work we and others have
found that in fact both linguistic
structure and linguistic meaning matter
but another cool line of work I'll
mention very briefly briefly is that in
line with the selectivity that we see in
our brain Imaging work evidence from
patients with brain damage damage to the
language system tells the same story and
that's very cool when very different
methods converge so remember I mentioned
that if you damage parts of the language
system in adulthood you typically will
have language deficits or what is
referred to as Aphasia in some cases
damage is so extensive it can basically
Wipe Out the whole language system and
you end up with basically a lack of any
ability to understand or produce
languages conditions known as Global
Aphasia totally devastating
um very very um uh difficult thing to
live with but you can ask okay these
patients have severe language deficits
what can they still do can they still
solve math problems can they play chess
like they used to can they write music
if they wrote music prior to their
damage and it turns out strikingly that
they can do all of these things the only
thing that these people can do is
convert the rich thoughts same richness
as they were before into sequences of
words to convey those thoughts to others
and they can't extract meaning from
others um linguistic utterances but
everything else is the same
okay so now we'll go back to the
statement I made that language areas are
selective for language
they're selected for language
what the hell is language anyway what is
a good definition of language right
I told you that things like and people
sometimes use this word very Loosely but
I told you that things like math which
people sometimes talk about like the
language of math or music or body
language these things apparently don't
activate the same parts of the brain
thus understanding natural language and
but if we think of this kind of maybe
there's some kind of a Continuum from
not being language to being language
there are some things that fall more
kind of in between these things and one
of those things
um is computer languages programming
languages right so um and even over in
our group right there did beautiful work
looking at how brains of people who
understand computer code respond to
understanding code now like natural
languages computer code can convey quite
a range of languages but it's a pretty
restricted kinds of meanings that you
can convey with computer code and
um it turns out that the language system
doesn't respond much to computer
languages and instead these languages
load on a system that we have in our
brains that we use for processing kind
of General complex problems so math
mathematics also loads on the system all
sorts of other novel problem solving uh
does as well
okay
so now what we're here today for what
about constructed languages where do
they fall here the reason to think that
they might recruit the language system
is that well like natural languages
there are communication systems that
allow you to express any meaning you
want pretty much there's some
constraints every now and then right but
mostly like you should be able to
express any meaning about the world or
your thoughts about the world to another
individual who knows the language but
reasons to think that they may not load
on natural language processing
mechanisms is that they differ in key
ways like Damian already mentioned
um when exactly linguistic capacity
emerged in the human lineage remains
debated but regardless of the precise
timestamp it's been a while languages
have been around for minimally uh 500
000 were years but probably over a
million by a lot of um recent kind of
estimates and during this time languages
have been changing they've been
co-volving with our bodies our brains
our societies again as Damian mentioned
our cultures have changed enormously
during this period and of course most
con languages construct languages have
much shorter time spans
um and they're also not really typically
well natural languages are very strongly
shaped by some combination of pressures
for efficient information transmission
right like the way we normally use
languages and kind of conversational
interactive settings as well as by
pressures of learning ease right and you
know modulo the Klingon for kid who well
for I don't know it's interesting
um but aside from that aside from that
there's not many cases of kids growing
up learning conflicts so there's just
that pressure is not there for a kid to
be able to acquire this language instead
like we learned the pressures on
conlangs are really very different kind
of pressures so drum roll archon Lang
similar enough to Natural languages to
recruit the same brain system or do they
load on General problem solving
mechanisms much like math and computer
languages and Simon will tell you the
answer which she already has
dancer
all right
so what I'm going to do is something
risky which is a follow-up these amazing
line of speakers but also give you very
very preliminary results obviously the
point of this conference was to have you
all come here and scan your brains now
we haven't been able to analyze all the
data but we were very lucky that we had
conlang speakers for some of the
languages living around the area who
came earlier and so we are going to
share what we found from their data
um so uh some of you have already
experienced this but most of you might
be wondering okay what is happening in
the scanner what is this fmri study at
all so I'm just going to briefly go
through some of the tasks that we do
there we do an English reading task
where you're reading things like
sentences that appear one word at a time
on your screen and then you're reading
non-words and I love to describe them as
Wordle guesses that Wordle tells you or
not words
and we also have an English auditory
task that is very similar to the
kanglang auditory task that all our
online creators helped us develop so
people will be listening to some Kant
Lang for instance
so hopefully everyone heard that and
then there's a version where we muffle
the sound so you're not getting any
linguistic input there I kind of
describe it as listening to the radio
where you're trying to turn it up to see
what people are saying but you can't
quite get what they're saying so it
sounds something like this
[Music]
hopefully hopefully you heard that
in addition to that we also tested
against a non-linguistic task so that
produces demand in your working memory
so there's a task where we show you a
grid and we tell you keep track of this
blue square in the grid as you can see
it's coming up a few times and then I'm
going to ask you which of these two
grids you just saw and then we tell
people whether they were right or wrong
and there's an easy version and a hard
version where people get very very
frustrated trying to keep track of these
two blue grids but in a first
as many first for this weekend I
actually had someone get all of them
right so you but the point of this task
is to have you be very engaged in this
working memory demand
all right so I'm just gonna go through
each uh language and as we can see here
is how strongly the language areas
respond to these tasks
um and I only have data again for a
couple of speakers for these languages
so I'm just gonna uh preface that um so
all right what happens with reading
English sentences so your language
Network responds to English sentences
but not to the non-word condition the
response is much lower however and this
is what the English sentences would look
like in one of the participants that
came in
on the other hand this is what the
working memory how the working member
like the language regions
um respond to the working memory demand
and as you can see it does not right
what I'm plotting here is zero on the
line now the question is what happens
with Esperanto
um so how many of you think we're gonna
see there's two options here one would
be it patterns up like the English
sentences and the English non-words or
it could pattern like the working memory
demands where like the language system
is not responding so who wants to raise
their uh raise your hand if you think it
patterns as the English sentences and
not words
all right
uh anyone going for the working memory
um pattern
um that's a great question they were
pretty fluent um not the most fluent of
the lot that we are scanning all right
so you were all right it did matter with
English
and this is what it looks like um in the
brain and just a reminder this is not a
competition between the compound
creators all right so on to Klingon so
again we have the data for one subject
um who um you know their English system
is responding the same way um as we saw
before
um the way the language system is
responding not responding to this
working memory task and the question is
um how is it responding to Klingon
um so who thinks it's responding just
like the English sentences
I'm surprised to see the Creator I'm not
racing their hands
all right so here we go
and this is what it looks like in here
next one up is Navi
um so again we see in this one speaker
that we tested the same pattern for
eight responding the language system
responding to English
um and it's not responding
to the spatial working memory test it
um
and if you think uh the navi the
language system is responding to Navi
similar to how it does for English
all right there we go
um you were all right
yeah um that's why it's tricky too so
David is asking why the working memory
is up instead of them that's why we
should never present data just from one
subject
um
um you know on average it tends to be
lower
um but you're all here and I know you
had questions so here I'm providing some
answers
go ahead
I love it I have experiences with us
throughout the speaker especially an
autistic Esperanto speaker I know a lot
of traveling people are neurodivergent
in some way words like ADHD
autism or whatever and I noticed
especially since you do working memory
which a lot of people with
like other neural divergencies struggle
with I I kind of wonder how will they be
different from like neurotypical
combling speakers
because like I just run through that
because like obviously like um
I I feel like you know you know autistic
well I'm like you know respond to what
you would do
that
um from my understanding of the research
the the way the language system for
um autistic people responds is similar
to uh non-autoistic people so we don't
expect differences in the languages so
we might expect differences in other
systems in the brain
working memory because I know like
that's definitely all like executive
function like working memory is often
like hard for people
yeah absolutely so so those would tap as
EV mentioned into a different system and
then we might expect differences in fact
we know that the way the working memory
system responds um or like this system
that responds to the working memory uh
task
um it it correlates the extent to which
it's active is how well you do in the
task right so there might so there's
differences there between people
definitely but not in the language
system yeah
um all right on to High Valyrian so
again we have data actually from two
speakers
um so here's the pattern for uh English
sentences here's the pattern for working
memory demands
um what okay raise your hand if you
believe it is patterning it with English
um
David has faith in his timeline yay I
didn't see what Paul uh on you raise
your hand for a navi all right great
and there we go it does this well
um so yay one more so I'm going to go
ahead and place these con legs next to
this other natural languages
all right and that is what I have for
you today I wanted to say a big thank
you for all the EV lab members for
helping scan during this Marathon
scanning session a very particular uh
Maya here who has done everything from
pretending to be a participant to show
you how everything goes to organizing
everyone so thank you everyone
[Applause]
and next we're going to have Thomas do
the last round of trivia
yeah that's a great question well as
I've said the language system responds
to both a written and auditory
um
language
um and people who've done the task in
the scanner know we're doing both the
reading the English sentences as well as
doing the auditory uh task where you're
listening to passages in English and the
pattern is the same I think we just have
a strong bias to present the written
version just because in our lab that's
like the main task that everyone tends
to do and we have data from 800 people
to compare it to but it's the same
pattern in this case for written and
auditory
yeah
um
those capacity for written value to sort
of prayers
just like I said I've heard something
was to speak as it basically basically
it's because it's in there and you know
I've seen some you know some there are
some things that seem to be consistent
with that assumption like like people
make like people confusing words it's
not like people mixing up words that are
pronounced the same when writing quickly
even if they know better when examining
characters yeah no I mean it's a great
question spoken in written language are
two completely different things right
like you you get exposed to spoken
language and then you pick up the
language as a child now even if you get
exposed to like a lot of writing
um as a child unless someone's
instructing you to learn how to read and
how to map those sounds to the letters
you're not going to pick up reading so
it needs a lot of instruction
um so there are definitely differences
between the two um
or not I mean do you think I mean does
It ultimately sort of go through spoken
language because I've heard people speak
as if it does I don't know what you mean
by that I feel like nothing goes through
I mean does anyone actually I mean do
people actually process
um written language directly without
access to a phonological level or our
people who are reading generally have a
phonological representation
there's a lot of difference in how
people read it's just other proficient
leaders don't have to go through the
chronology
that many people do and and even for
proficient leaders there is some
variability but like for example your
auditory cortex is not active when
you're reading it whether your language
is more just the same as when it's
interesting and there's a specialized
feeding bits okay there are some yeah
one last you guys promises the last one
but if you've done given any thought to
studying less naturalistic constructive
languages like say tokipona or logical
to what extent those might resemble or
not resemble yeah I'd love to test as
many languages as possible but we are
limited by time and speakers so yeah
hopefully one day yeah
all right do we are we good on time
let's take maybe one more question okay
oh we have the Gabe section so okay okay
the games will like all be there perfect
yeah you can always find us to talk
about this
um I don't know who went first this is
go ahead just because
have you looked at the people's uh
linguistic
processing that have a Fantasia could
not have any visual memories whatsoever
uh it's not that they don't have visual
memories they don't have visual imagery
all right so when they think about stuff
unlike most people apparently they don't
visualize things in their Mind's Eye
um we haven't
um I don't I mean uh people have studied
that population but not with respect to
language as far as I know I know you
seem to think I I think inner voice
might be about a cold or match which we
still haven't studied but I don't know
either he wants to but when if they
don't have a visual imager we also don't
have the visual memories like the
childhood memories do not exist in
pictures your mother's stage does not
exist in pictures that's why I was
asking because most of the memories are
actually in a verbal way why do you
think language would be different than
those individuals because I was at home
on quiet and interested in uh difference
and fmri images out of memories other
people who do have visual ability versus
the people who don't
yeah I mean there is work on application
if you drop me a line I can send you
some papers of that population but
yeah and I would always be happy to take
more questions out at the reception we
we don't have time for one more I'm so
sorry
yep
laughs
go ahead all right on to the last trivia
question okay so I realized that I am
the last thing standing between you and
the uh bar outside and asking all the
questions to the researchers and
everything but we do want to give our
prizes to our top performing trivia
participants so we're just going to go
through the each of the languages and
we're going to have the Conlan Creator
if that person is alive
um ask a question okay so uh could we
please start with the uh Navi speakers
and could you please come forward and we
will have
um a question from Peter
um it's up to you to decide and also the
um
we will like we don't have buzzers so
we're going to have to just well sort of
do an honor System raise your hand as
soon as you have the answer and then
um yeah we'll call on you and hopefully
we'll be a yeah fair with
umpiring so
so the not the trivia question is
which of the following four not the
words
did Paul have to come up with on the
spot one day when he was on set
ready okay one
game
two
three
in
foreign
you got it
good okay so if you are at the first
place you can take your pick of either
the Duolingo plushie or the pin and
second place can take the remaining item
could I could I add one thing
that word by the way means ass
so next up we'll have a question from
David and um so we didn't have enough
speakers to run a trivia for all the uh
Dothraki and Valerian speakers but if
you are a speaker of Dothraki or
Valyrian uh please step forward and
you'll be automatically eligible for one
of these prizes because there weren't
enough speakers to run a trivia
Improvement is here
so we have Reuben do we have Jill or
Vanessa
okay well you still have to answer the
question but
even if you lose you can still you know
get first
okay oh it's not written up here do I
just have to remember what I said uh
yeah all right okay all right first do
the Rocky or Valerian which one do you
want all right uh how many words and
names combined of Dothraki did George R
Martin create
third something
how close how close how close hang on
how close does he need to get within 10
within five Within 20.
100.
I'm going to give it to you it was 56.
56 words and names
for high Valerian four
oh yeah same same question which how
many no that was just how many words
because there were a bunch of names how
many High Valyrian Wards did George R
Martin create and that was four
[Applause]
okay so next up we'll have the Klingon
speakers the two top Klingon finalists
You Know Who You Are
you gotta get your battle cries in
and we'll have a question from Mark
all right now the difficulty here
especially with these two
is they know more cling on trivia than I
do
if I ask him too
so I think the way this game is going to
work is more is more like Jeopardy so
the the
and what I mean by that is it doesn't
matter what you know it's how you work
the buzzer okay because you probably
both get it nevertheless
there's two published meaning in paper
um
dictionaries of Klingon there's the
Klingon dictionary but also in Klingon
for the galactic traveler there's a like
a supplementary dictionary
on the Klingon English side of that
dictionary
which is called Klingon what is it
called Klingon Federation standard or so
we stopped using the word English at
some point okay the very first word
is
what's interesting about that
it is
um
entry is an error and the word means
error right
good job
it's interesting to observe like who
chooses what for the first versus second
place privilege
I think so this one has some House of
the Dragon you know theme so that might
affect the uh choices
um okay so for the final category it'll
be Esperanto and unfortunately we could
not get zamanhof to come join us
um but uh Simon will be taking the place
of the conline Creator to ask the final
question
all right so this question was asked by
uh Cardwell Ramsey Cardwell from
Duolingo and my students oh oh boy
oh yeah all right
and the question is
who are Adam and Sophia
[Laughter]
do we know
I think there's enough prices for both
of them
yeah yeah
all right yeah you got it
you can
[Applause]
and with that Much Ado thank you
everyone for attending I'm not gonna
stand in the way of your drinks and
mingling with each other um go ahead
[Applause]